Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So Leute, es war heute wirklich schwierig auf YouTube ein paar Sachen zu finden, die
man sich angucken kann.
Da war wirklich nur Schrott dabei, so wie halt einfach 95% von YouTube nun mal ist.
Jetzt muss ich mich ein bisschen leiser machen.
Moin, ja also muss ich echt sagen 90% von YouTube ist so schwachsinnig, was da gibt.
Also nicht mal lustig schwachsinnig, sondern einfach für'n Arsch.
Guck mal, wir machen jetzt mal was.
Wir gehen jetzt mal kurz hier auf Trends in, achso im Moment, ich hab mein Dings auf Browser
auf Englisch stehen.
Ja ne, dann, dann nicht, dann nicht.
Ah doch hier Trending Videos, ja.
What the fuck?
Also Trending, ich weiß nicht, wem das gefällt, was da unter Trending Videos ist, meiner mag
vielleicht mal das ein oder andere dabei sein, aber das war einfach nur übelster Schrott.
Residenz Sleeper
Nein, keine Ahnung, kenne ich mich nicht mit aus mit, ich glaube Lancom hatte ich noch nie
was in der Hand, ja, kannst du verwenden.
Ich hoffe sogar, dass ich demnächst vielleicht was rausbringe ohne IPv4, nur mit IPv6, dass
man kein extra Geld für IPv4 bezahlen muss.
Triebull und Dankeschön für den Sub, ja ich war ja gestern, ah es labert denn, gestern,
Schwachsinn, äh letzte Woche, also nein diese Woche eigentlich noch, es ist ja Sonntag,
ja ist Sonntag schon erster Tag von der neuen Woche oder ist Sonntag letzter Tag von der
alten Woche, wie handhabt ihr das, also für mich ist es der letzte Tag von der alten Woche.
Naja zumindest ich war ja diese Woche, Sonntag ist alte Woche, genau, sehe ich auch so, ich
war ja irgendwie das dritte Mal oder so auf der Arbeit in Frankfurt und ich habe mir gleich
irgendwas eingefangen, nicht wirklich schlimm, aber ich merke das im Hals, dass ich irgendwas
im Hals habe, gleich mal in der Bahn gewesen und irgendeinen Scheiß eingefangen, es wird
wahrscheinlich nicht Corona sein, weil das ist wahrscheinlich anders, ja, außerdem
bin ich geimpft, vielleicht ist es ja, vielleicht ist es ja Corona und weil ich geimpft bin,
merke ich kaum was von, keine Ahnung, zumindest sagt das richtig, ich habe jetzt gelesen,
dass die Dänen haben jetzt gesagt Corona gibt es nicht mehr, also haben gesagt ist
vorbei bei uns, all die Dänen haben es eh drauf was das angeht.
Ich hatte mal einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit, der kam aus Dänemark und eins konnte der richtig
gut, das war sich, wie soll ich sagen, nicht hetzen lassen, doch habe ich, natürlich habe
ich das, ich habe mich zweimal impfen lassen und das ist jetzt keine Ahnung, drei Monate
her oder drei Wochen her oder vier Wochen her oder so, also wenn ich jetzt keinen Impfschutz
habe, dann weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich Corona habe, ich glaube ich habe irgendwas anderes im Hals
und weiß ja nie.
Aber die Dänen haben es eh drauf, wie gesagt ich hatte mal einen dänischen Kollege, der
hatte echt das Talent dafür sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen zu lassen.
Das Wetter, das ist wie mein Opa oder die Oma auch, mein Opa hat immer gesagt so nach
dem Motto, genau, so nach dem Motto, ah mein Fuß tut weh, mein Fuß tut weh, das liegt am
Wetter oder ah das Knie tut weh, das liegt am Wetter, Puzzle-Meister, danke für den
Sub.
Was ja kompletter Schwachsinn ist, das habe ich damals, damals habe ich ihm das versucht
zu erklären, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, das liegt nicht am Wetter, habe ich ihm versucht
das zu erklären, dass es eher Zufall ist, wenn das übereinstimmt, aber nein, nein, nein,
er war der Meinung, er merkt auch in seinem Fuß, wenn sich das Wetter ändert, er hat
gesagt, ah mein Fuß tut weh, das Wetter wird anders und wenn das Wetter dann anders geworden
ist, dann hat er gesagt, Zilste, ich habe es gewusst und wenn das Wetter sich nicht
geändert hat, hat er gesagt, das kommt noch, weil ich meine, irgendwann wird sich das Wetter
schon in nächster Zeit ändern, ne?
Madminister, huge subscriptions, vier Monate hier, nice.
Gut, das kann ja was mit, ja Moment, du sagst ja aber nicht, dass du Wetteränderung-Tage
oder sowas im Voraus erkennst, dadurch, dass du Kopfschmerzen bekommst, du sagst, hey,
wenn sich heute das Wetter ändert, dann kriege ich Kopfweh, das kann ich mir schon vorstellen,
aber der hat ja gesagt, so nach dem Motto, mitten am Tag, ah mein Fuß tut weh, das Wetter
wird anders, so das war einfach so random guess.
Wie hast du die Impfung vertragen?
Also, erste Impfung, hatte ich ein bisschen Kopfweh und war ziemlich müde, so ein, zwei
Tage und mir hat der Arm wehgetan, war kein Problem, zweite Impfung war im Prinzip genau
das gleiche, nur ein bisschen ausgeprägt, also ich hatte übelst Kopfweh einen Tag lang,
so dass ich gar nicht vor dem Rechner sitzen konnte, aber dann ging es auch, der Arm hat
mir zwei, drei Tage wehgetan, dann war es vorbei, also ich habe überhaupt gar keine
Probleme gehabt, größerer Art, ne, mit der Corona-Impfung, so sind ja, ich habe übrigens
BioNTech gekriegt, so sind ja gerade am überlegen, ob es jetzt nicht noch eine dritte Runde oder
so gibt, lass ich auch machen, wenn das sinnvoll ist, lass ich das auch machen, dritte Runde,
in your ass, ne, in den Arm, nicht in the ass, ja ich glaube das hatten die meisten, wenn
du mal so nachguckst, Nebenwirkung Corona-Impfung, das ist im Prinzip, im Prinzip sagt jeder
müde und Kopfweh, das ist glaube ich Standard, das ist auch nicht schlecht, ja, verstehen
bloß, Battlefield 3 Spieler, so was gucken wir dann heute mal, Leute ich muss, ich muss,
ich muss aber sagen, ihr wisst ja, ihr wisst ja, ich bin alt, ja, ich höre mich vielleicht
auf Twitch nicht so an und vielleicht, vielleicht kommt das auch nicht so rüber, wenn ich hier
was von Poggers, Fivehead, sonst was erzähle, aber ihr wisst ja, ich bin alt, ich bin 37
jetzt, ja, kann man sich nicht, kann man sich oftmals nicht vorstellen, aber ich bin 37
jetzt, ja, okay und mir ist, mir ist, ich habe mir da letztes Mal gelangentube gemacht,
zufällig, weiß nicht, ich glaube als ich im Klo war oder so, wisst ihr, besser Ort,
wo man sich Gedanken macht, zumindest, was mir aufgefallen ist, auf dem Klo, also was
mir aufgefallen ist, dass eigentlich 1984 das beste Geburtsdatum überhaupt ist, wisst
ihr auch, warum 1984 das beste Geburtsdatum ist, nicht, weil der erste Mac released wurde
1984, nicht, dass das jetzt wirklich jemand interessiert da, nachhinein, aber, nein, deswegen
auch nicht, 1984 oder es kann auch 83, 84, 85, 86 oder so, ist egal, also, warum, folgendermaßen,
folgendermaßen, also, warum ich denke, dass das das beste, beste Geburts, sagen wir mal,
Jahrzehnt ist, du hast alles mitgekriegt, du hattest Pre-Computer, also ich hatte ja,
sagen wir mal so, die ersten, sagen wir mal so, 10 Jahre meines Lebens, ja, vielleicht
nicht, na doch, na doch, sagen wir mal so, die ersten 10 Jahre meines Lebens hatte ich
überhaupt nichts mit Computer zu tun, meine, gab es zwar damals schon, aber das war überhaupt
nicht verbreitet, damals hat auch keiner wirklich einen Computer daheim gehabt, später hatte
dann vielleicht mal jemand mit Amiga oder so, die Oldschool Leute, Atari oder sowas, aber
es war, war nichts, ne, also sprich, ich hatte 10 Jahre, ganz klassisch, ganz klassisch so
Outdoor Kindheit, so, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, ja, man ist dann, man ist dann
in die Luft und in die Sonne und so, total, kann man sich auch gar nicht vorstellen, so,
ganz, so, das hatte ich 10 Jahre und danach hatte ich, bam, Internet, Computerstells daheim,
ich hab komplett, also ich hab komplett Internetaufstieg, Computer daheimaufstieg, Gamingaufstieg
und sowas mitgekriegt, dazu kam, dass das noch Pre-Smartphone war, ich hab auch noch
Pre-Smartphone mitgekriegt, ich war voll dabei, quasi jetzt auch noch Post-Smartphone, also
ich hab im Prinzip alle wichtigen Entwicklungen durch mitbekommen, was richtig nice ist eigentlich
und nix davon zu lang, es wäre nämlich scheiße gewesen früher geboren zu sein, weil dann
bist du dann, dann wärst du dann schon so festgefahren, ja, 94, das ist alles noch
im Rahmen, ja, aber dann wärst du so, stell dir mal vor, du wärst 74 geboren, dann wär
ich jemand gewesen, der gesagt hätte, ähm, der gesagt hätte, ah, Computerzeug, nee,
geh mal mal weg, äh, da will ich nix mit zu tun haben, da hätte ich wahrscheinlich
wirklich das gemacht, was das Arbeitsamt gesagt hat, ich hätte was mit Holz gelernt, ja,
also ich find, das 1984 ist eigentlich der beste, beste Geburtsjahr überhaupt, das Jahr
des Linux Desktops, ja, genau, ich dachte 2022 wird das Jahr des Linux Desktops, soll
ich euch sagen, wann realistisch gesehen das Jahr des Linux Desktops wird, nie, es wird
nie das Jahr des Linux Desktops, außer, außer, es kommt in einer ganz anderen Form, als wir
uns das denken, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Chrome OS oder sowas nochmal groß rauskommt, oder
Steam OS oder, ähm, keine Ahnung, Desktop Android, keine Ahnung, dann vielleicht in
einer anderen Form, als wir uns das denken, und ja, ich finde auch, das Jahr des Linux
Desktops war im Prinzip schon der beste, also der coolste Linux Desktops waren die Zeiten,
wo, äh, Compets und Barrel und sowas angesagt war mit, mit, äh, mit solchen Dingern hier,
ja, mit solchen Dingern, ja, wobbly Windows und warum auch immer die da jetzt, warum man
das Magus Lanz anhat, aber ok, ja, so, diese Views dann 3D Desktop mit Würfel, ja, durchgeschaltet,
das gibt es heute teilweise immer noch, aber bei weitem nicht mehr so abgedreht, ja, die
guten Funktionen, also die seriösen Funktionen, das ist auch so cool, die seriösen Funktionen
haben sie behalten, aber, ähm, so dieses ganze ultraverspielte und abgedrehte, das
haben sie ja meistens, das hier, so Dinger da, ne, das war schon, war schon cool, oder
die Fenster, die dann abgefackelt sind, wenn du sie geschlossen hast und sowas, KeckW 3D,
ja, das war noch was, das fand ich richtig cool, das war für mich so die spannendste
Zeit von Linux Desktop, weil es einfach cool war und, und, sag mal mal, Möglichkeiten,
die andere Betriebssysteme gar nicht hatten, das konnte damals weder Windows noch Mac,
ja gut, was anderes gibt es nicht, das war richtig cool, aber sie haben da nie wirklich
was, was draus gemacht, ich mein, gut, man muss ja sagen, die Usability macht es jetzt
nicht wirklich besser, ne, ich hatte damals auf der Arbeit übrigens ein Rechner, wenn
du mal kurz, kurz husten, so, schau dir mal Wayfire an, sagt mir gar nichts, aber da
muss ja Wayland für verwenden, Wayland Compositor, das können wir uns vielleicht mal angucken
irgendwann, da müssen wir mal gucken, ob das was taucht, äh, warte mal, Stream, Stream-Ideen,
hier, bam, haben wir 3D, 3D, Descope, ne, zumindest, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
also ich hab ja damals meine Ausbildung angefangen und ich hatte damals, das übelste, übelster
Schrott, ja, mir wurde damals, natürlich hab ich ein Rechner auf der Arbeit bekommen,
der Desktop, das ist doch Poggers Desktop, ich find instant auf alles, alles auf meinem
Desktop, so, ich hab, ich hab ja damals die Ausbildung angefangen, also irgendwie vor,
vor 20 Jahren, ne, vor 2007 rum, egal, zumindest, die haben ja, die haben auf der Arbeit damals
ein Rechner gestellt und das war irgendein selbst zusammengebauter Rechner aus Einzelteilen
von Alternate damals, das war der schlechteste, billigste Rechner überhaupt, das Ding hat
quasi, wenn du es rum, wenn du es gerutscht hast auf den Boden, hat sich das Gehäuse
gebogen, ja, kennt ihr das, wenn die, wenn ihr Sachen habt, wo die Platten, wo die Platten
zu dünn sind, also wenn das hier so euer Gehäuse von vorne ist, ja, das ist euer Gehäuse
von vorne und ich hab das Gehäuse verrutscht, dann sah das Gehäuse so aus, so schlecht war
das Gehäuse, ich hab das verschoben, das Gehäuse vom Rechner, dann sah das so aus danach,
zumindest, das ist meiner billigste Kackrechner, den man überhaupt jemanden zur Verfügung
stellen konnte und damals weiß ich noch, da war ich den ersten Tag da, ich hatte nicht
großartig Ahnung, nicht Ahnung von Linux und da meinte einer zu mir so nach dem Motto
hier, guck mal, hier hast du dein Rechner, installiere dir mal ein Linux drauf, so, was
hab ich damals gemacht, das war da übrigens, der Rechner war für die damalige Zeit schon
richtig kacke, also ich hab, einzige was ich großartig gekannt hab, ich hab da Ubuntu
Desktop drauf gemacht, natürlich gleich mal, gleich mal Compets, weil das CPU gerendert
auch alles so langsam, war Compets, so und dann ist mir irgendwann aufgefallen, der Rechner
kackt ab und dann hab ich den Rechner aufgemacht, hab mal reingeguckt und hab festgestellt,
da war eine AMD Grafikkarte drin, also erstens damals AMD Treiber unter Linux, ganz ganz
abenteuerliche Geschichte, musste ich erstmal das neueste installieren, aber was mir dann
aufgefallen ist, ich hab den Rechner aufgemacht, reingeguckt und hab festgestellt, aha, das
ist ja eine Grafikkarte ohne, das ist ja eine Grafikkarte mit Lüfter, aber ich hör gar
keinen Lüfter und da hab ich die Grafikkarte mir angeguckt und der Rechner war schon so
alt und kaputt, das war irgendwie verkrustet im Lüfter, sprich, die haben mir den Rechner
auf der Arbeit gestellt, wer weiß wie alt das gewesen ist, mit irgendwie verkrustet
im CPU, verkrustet im GPU Lüfter, der sich nicht mal gedreht hat, hab ich das Ding aufgeschraubt,
kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern, hab ich das Ding aufgeschraubt, hab da ein bisschen
dran rumgefuddelt an dem Lüfter, das Problem ist nur, ich hab's dann schlimmer gemacht,
ich hab den Rechner dann eingeschaltet und der Lüfter ging wieder, aber vorher war Ruhe
und nachdem ich eingeschaltet habe, nachdem ich an dem Lüfter rumgespielt hab, hat der
Lüfter dann gemacht, was natürlich schlecht war im Büro, das ging erstmal allen auf den
Sack, so, na gut, wirklich kühler geblieben ist die Grafikkarte dann auch nicht davon
und jetzt kommt Big Brain, Big Brain Hack, das würd ich heute auch nicht mehr machen,
aber damals war das noch so die Zeit von, man ist auch mit CD's ins Rechenzentrum und
sowas, das war alles so, jetzt durfte man alles nicht so eng nehmen, so oder nicht so
eng sehen und ich hab dann einfach den Grafikkartenlüfter komplett abgestöpselt, ne nicht Aluplok,
das ist die der Bauer Taktik, Aluplok drauf, ich hab dann einfach, hatte ich ja auch nicht,
ich hab dann einfach, ich hab dann einfach das Gehäuse aufgelassen, ich hab den Grafikkartenlüfter
ausgesteckt, also ich hab den Strom rausgestöpselt, was auch nicht so einfach war, weil das Ding,
das weißt du, das Kabel war einmal oder zweimal um die Grafikkarte drum herum gewickelt, ich
hab den Lüfter ausgestöpselt und ich hab das Gehäuse an der Seite aufgelassen, so
und das hat genau gereicht, ein offenes Gehäuse ausgestöpselt im Grafikkartenlüfter, dass
das Ding bei irgendwie, was weiß ich, 93 Grad oder so, stable im Desktopbetrieb gelaufen
ist, das war irgendein Celeron CPU, das war der beschissenste Arbeitsrechner aller Zeiten,
normalen Browser konnte ich da drauf auch nicht gescheit verwenden, das war zu langsam,
hab ich damals Opera verwendet, weil es das einzige lief, also Azubi Ausstattung war wirklich
grausam damals, aber ich hab's, ich hab's hingekriegt, ja und da hatte ich solche Dinge
auf dem Desktop und seitdem war ich immer großer Fan von Wobbly Windows, Wobbly Windows
ist einfach in der Windows 10, ne da funktioniert die Hälfte da nicht, wie das geht, Wobbly
Windows unter Windows, Windows FX, ok man muss irgendeinen komischen Crap Purchsen,
so geht das unter Windows zeig ich mal her, ja ja, wisst ihr, das sind immer die geilsten
Videos, erstmal ein Installer, dann haben wir Klicks zusammen, das ist da wahrscheinlich
nicht mit irgendwelchen Games kompatibel oder so, ja Wobbly Windows exquisite, aber halt
unter, unter, unter Linux, ne, Wobbly Windows, jawoll so muss das sein, so und ich hab damals
halt gedacht, ich kann nie wieder einen Rechner verwenden ohne Wobbly Windows, aber seitdem
ich auf Tiling Window Manager umgestiegen bin, aber das ist auch schon keine Ahnung
wie lange her, ja gibt's halt keine Wobbly Windows mehr, weil's überhaupt keine Windows
mehr, weil's keine Windows mehr gibt in dem Fall, oder sagen wir mal es gibt nur noch
maximierte Windows, also ihr hört's vielleicht, ich hab irgendwas im Hals heute, seit ein paar
Tagen schon, aber ich bin garantiert in Frankfurt oder im Zug von und nach Frankfurt, Frankfurt
Frankfurt, warum sieht man hier eigentlich Füße, zum Glück hat er jetzt nicht ein bisschen
weiter hochgescrollt, Alter, ah wir compilen Chrome, alles klar, ja Moment, das da ist
aber nicht Chrome compilen, das ist, das ist CAT auf, keine Ahnung, DEV SDA oder sowas,
das ist kein Chrome compilen, so YouTube hast nochmal eine Chance uns was Gutes vorzuschlagen,
CAT auf gesamten Linux Köln, ne, das so sieht das ungefähr aus, wenn du CAT auf DEV SDA
oder sowas machst, ja jetzt hab ich auch gelesen, bei denen ist Corona jetzt vorbei, denen haben
gesagt, Moment, nein das haben sie nicht gesagt, die haben gesagt, so haben gesagt Corona ist
vorbei, ok also ihr seht heute mal die YouTube Empfehlungen sind wirklich grausam wieder,
was ist denn das alles, new old stock 17 Zoll CRT Monitor, ah das muss ich mir angucken,
old school shit, aber ein bisschen Vorspulen, Sekunde, warte mal, Chat gucken, ich hab ein
komplettes System Backup mit R-Sync gemacht, kann man machen, ja, kann man machen, du kannst
das mit R-Sync so out of the box, jetzt kein komplettes Plattendump inklusive Bootloader
und sonst was ziehen, aber die wichtigen Sachen Backup kannst du mit R-Sync, ja, äh, nö,
solltet ihr eigentlich zumindest mal die, zeigt ihr das nicht, die aktuell zumindest geladenen
Module an, keine Ahnung, oder ne, das zeigt ihr an wo die liegen auf der Platte, ne, ach
was weiß ich aus dem Kopf, keine Ahnung, alle 12 Monate Hyper Subscription hier, huge, meine
Linux Distribution zerstört sich irgendwie immer selbst, ich hab nix gemacht, das ja,
was sagen sie alle, ich hab nix gemacht, vielleicht ist da ne Platte im Arsch, ich mein wenn sich
Sachen bei mir auf der, vor allem wenn das noch ne Magnetplatte ist, immer von selbst
zerstören würde ich mir mal gedacht, vielleicht ist da ne Festplatte im Arsch, ja, es geht
mir auch so, ich kann mir Wayland nicht geben, das Problem ist, das Problem ist, ich flame
immer gern über Wayland, ne, aber ich verwende das so selten, dass meine Infos meistens
schon outdated sind und ich die Hälfte schon wieder vergessen hab, was mir eigentlich
auf den Kicks geht.
Das letzte Mal weiß ich noch, konnte man, konnte man, ähm, Anwendungen nicht richtig,
äh, größer und kleiner machen, dann hat er nämlich nicht das Fenster größer und
kleiner gemacht, sondern er hat die Anwendung komplett in der Originalauflösung gelassen
und hat die einfach nur hoch und runter skaliert, ganz, ganz merkwürdig, ich war damals schon
passiv Kühlung Pionier, ja, ich hab halt passiv gekühlt, nämlich ich die Lüfte raus
gestöpselt hab, was soll eigentlich der Vorteil von Wayland sein, der Vorteil von Wayland
sollte mal, oder ist noch, ich weiß ich gar nicht so genau, sollte mal sein, dass es halt
moderner, leichtgewichtiger und besser zu maintainen ist als X, das mag auch so sein,
da kann ich, kann ich nix zu sagen, ich mein ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dass X wirklich
50 Jahre alter Schrott ist, aber, ähm, unter Linux verlassen sich so viele Dinge auf irgendwelche
Edge Cases, so Sachen die mal da waren und jetzt nicht mal da sind unter Wayland und
sonst wie, sodass im Prinzip Wayland wahrscheinlich mittlerweile komplexer wird als X, weil sie
noch Wayland plus alles alte von X unterstützen müssen.
Aber ich bin da jetzt nicht im Bilde, was das angeht, Pegger, Dankeschön für den Sub,
ich hab übrigens, ich hab übrigens gelesen, das erzähl ich euch jetzt nicht, sonst gib
ein die Leute mit einem Chat rum, null, Ande, 12 Monate Hyper Subcription, Dankeschön,
hab ich glaube ich schon vorgelesen.
Daher braucht man ja auch noch X Wayland, ja wie gesagt, ich glaube, mittlerweile haben
die festgestellt, dass wir machen einfach mal was neues, schlankes, Problem problematisch
wird, wenn sie die Hälfte nicht unterstützen, was die Leute haben wollen.
So ich muss, ich muss mir jetzt mal kurz, wir gucken uns nicht das ganze Bild an, wenn
ich das ganze Video an, ich will einfach nur ein bisschen Oldschool Shit, jawoll, Akkusync,
ja die gab es damals, Akkusync und Syncmaster, Syncmaster war glaube ich Samsung, Syncmaster,
Samsung Syncmaster, wie die gibt es heute noch, das braucht doch keiner mehr, CRT,
jawoll, hab ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt, dass ich mich fast mal gekillt hätte, mit
einem Monitor, also in einem alternativen Universum bin ich heute gar nicht da, damals
ist mir mein Monitor abgeraucht und ich hab mir, also mein CRT, was, but why, na gut wir
müssen alle mal rum, wir müssen alle mal rum, mir ist damals mein Monitor abgeraucht,
sowas hier in der Richtung, 21 Zoll, 21 Zoll CRT Monitor und ich dachte mir damals, es
ist eine gute Idee, ich stöpsel den einfach ab und mach ihn auf, so und ich hab den abgestöpselt,
zum Glück hab ich den abgestöpselt, abgestöpselt und direkt aufgemacht, ohne noch mal einzuschalten
oder sonst was, dass das komplett der ganze Strom weg ist, also ich hätte mich da ohne
Probleme schocken können, ich war damals auch allein daheim, ich hätte keiner gefunden,
ich war einfach RIP gewesen und ich hab den aufgeschraubt und komplett drin rumgefingert,
also hätte auch in die Hose gehen, Leben am Limit ja, ja das sind, das sind, das sind,
das sind so dritte Welt Linux User Probleme ja, ich hab übrigens auch einen schönen
Bug mit meinem Laptop auf der Arbeit, manchmal, ich weiß nicht genau warum, ich vermute wenn
Leute irgendwie aus Versehen am Displayport wackeln oder was auch immer, zumindest kommt
das manchmal vor, dass mein Display nur mit 30 FPS läuft und Leute ich sag euch, wenn
ihr einen 240hz Monitor gewohnt seid und könnt so ein Fenster bewegen und ihr seid dann auf
der Arbeit und euer Bildschirm ist auf einmal, wenn ihr morgens euch dran setzt auf 30 FPS,
dann wirkt das anstatt so, wirkt das einfach nur, das ist so laggy, weil man muss dann
so einen ausstöpseln und dann geht das wieder, ja genau so, genau so ist das dann, so äh
einfach im Homeoffice bleiben hat man das Problem, richtig, meine Rede, meine Rede,
was auch geil ist, muss ich jetzt noch mal kurz loswerden, bei mir in der Firma haben
sie jetzt einen neuen Blogpost veröffentlicht wo sie auf die neue Corona Lage eingegangen
sind, also es ist ja so, dass gerade in Offenbach und Frankfurt die Inzidenzwert sind da wieder
Sputals hoch aber ich muss mal kurz gucken was heute offenbach ist offenbacher glaube ich 200
Aber sind jetzt auch schon alle auf den Drehsteg gekommen dass das als einzige aussage größt es vielleicht auch nicht so sinnvoll ist
So es ist zumindest hoch es fack gut die seite geht nicht warum auch immer tägliche übersicht
Ok es ist
Aber es wird 160 offenbacher 100 98
So zumindest
Zumindest gab es jetzt einen neuen blog post bei mir auf der arbeit
Offenbach ist pains jam ja oftbach ist richtiger offenbach ist somit das pains champions was du dir vorstellen kannst
Zumindest gab es jetzt einen neuen blog post bei mir auf der arbeit und das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt
Bei uns ist es immer so wenn es einen blog post gibt da wird dann keine ahnung von irgendeinem vorstandstyp oder irgendein management typ oder was auch immer der die rechte hat
sind immer die gleichen paar. Werden blog post verpasst verfasst
Und es gibt immer die gleichen handvoll leute oder zwei hände vor leute die das immer liken
Egal welcher blog post das ist die liken das immer so richtig schleimermäßig so nach wie vor blog post like
like und die haben glaube ich schon eine notification drauf wenn es einen blog post gibt weil
Dass sie möglichst schnell liken können weil wenn du als einer der ersten likest steht da nicht nur da
50 leute haben das geliked oder sondern steht dann da
Max wubblors hat geliked steht dann da
Ich glaube das bleibt dann sogar stehen für die ersten die geliked haben das heißt wenn man richtige schleimattacken hat
Das heißt wenn man richtige schleimattacken machen will muss man als erster immer ohne vorher zu lesen den blog post liken zumindest gab es jetzt
In den blog post zur aktuellen coronalage und das ist extrem widersprüchlich
Da steht so was da steht so was drinne wie
Wir freuen uns dass
unsere coronamaßnahmen so
so effektiv sind und wir
Gehen jetzt ja auch langsam über wieder in den normalbetrieb oder was auch immer sie da geschrieben haben und sie es freuen sich alle so
Dass sich endlich wieder alle im büro auf augenhöhe begegnen können und also übelste manager manager speak
Ich leiche nicht nein
So aber also sie schreiben im anfang quasi ok leute
Das ist jetzt die begründung für warum wir wollen dass ihr wieder ins büro kommt
Und dann steht ein satz unten drunter aber das wichtigste ist die gesundheit
Unsere mitarbeiter da habe ich mir gedacht wie schafft ihr das zwei setze hintereinander zu machen und euch so krass zu widersprechen
Erster satz jawoll leute
Endlich alle wieder ins büro und der zweite satz ist ja aber die gesundheit ist uns das wichtigste
Was zum das das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn
Einfach ganz davon abgesehen mich betrifft zum glück eh nur zum teil
Ich habe ja mein arbeitszeit modell geändert auf home office und ich bin jetzt dienstags bin ich dienstags bin ich in frankfurt
Wahrscheinlich planmäßig dienstags gehe ich jetzt immer nach frankfurt
Gebt mir da einen tag büro stelle immer wieder fest wie wahnsinnig ineffektiv das eigentlich ist
Und die restliche woche schon heim und macht dann auch was
Weil an dem tag wo ich im büro bin mache ich nix das ist nicht weil ich nichts machen will sondern weil es im büro einfach nicht
richtig funktioniert
Das ist ein großraum büro
Ich sitze da wo auch unser support sitzt das heißt damit öfters mal ein bisschen telefoniert was ich dann wirklich wild finde aber ich nerf die anderen
Wenn ich telefoniere weil ich irgendwelche team meetings habe dann hast du manchmal ein bisschen lauter telefoniert
Dann hast du irgendeiner der dir was erzählt dann willst du einmal kurz nur was fragen der erzählt dir eine halbe stunde was neu ist
Passiert ist du kannst im büro ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das früher gemacht habe du kannst im büro einfach nicht richtig arbeiten das funktioniert nicht
im vergleich zu daheim
Kennst du leute die so mega laut telefonieren klar
Ich muss aber sagen ich glaube ich telefoniere auch manchmal relativ laut weil ich habe meinen kopfhörer auf und ich mache das noise canceling schon immer aus
Aber ich habe meinen kopfhörer auf habe halt dann freisprechdings an und rede halt normal und ich glaube dass das wahrscheinlich auch in dem büro wo nicht viele leute drin sind gerade
Aber halt genug so dass man sich nervt dass das andere teilweise schon nervt wenn ich teams meeting mache außerdem du erwischst viele leute viel einfacher wenn sie daheim sind
Wenn jemand daheim ist und ich muss kurz was wissen sag ich ins teams guck ob der anwesend ist oder ob der letzte fünf minuten anwesend war oder irgendeinen status hat
Geh ins teams rein sag hier sag mal kannst du kurz gucken fertig dann meldet er sich meistens vor ort vor ort schreibst ihn an er meldet sich nicht
Du gehst rüber zum platz guckst wo er ist er ist nicht da und die sagen ah ich glaube der mietet gerade irgendwo ja bis wann ja keine ahnung
Das ist einfach für alle beteiligten viel besser wenn die leute daheim sind vor allem in der kombination wenn die leute was machen daheim
Ich bin aber trotzdem der meinung ich habe übrigens auch eine mechanische tastatur auf der arbeit ja ja ich kenne das ich kenne das ja auch eine mechanische tastatur aber ich habe silikonringe unter den wichtigsten tasten die ich haue
Also ich habe ja so den hang dazu die enter taste beispielsweise von meinem num block so zu hauen und das geht natürlich die leute auf zack deswegen habe ich da silikonring drunter und dann ist das nicht so schlimm
Ja aber ich bin ich bin der meinung man sollte einfach das den leuten anbieten und wer wirklich ins büro kommen will kann das ja machen da habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen wir haben zum beispiel einen der weiß ich das hat er mir erzählt ja dass das ihn seine kinder und frau daheim so nervt der geht lieber ins büro okay kann ich kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen wobei ich es halt nicht verstehe bei manchen leuten ja die dann in der küsse sitzen und meinen dort gescheit homeoffice
machen zu können da rennen die leute um dich drum herum du hast keine gescheiten armen leden und nix wie kommt man auf die idee dass man auf einem sofa auf einem stuhl in der küche oder sonst wo ordentlich homeoffice machen kann das heißt das heißt nicht umsonst office du brauchst einen arbeitsplatz du brauchst ordentlichen stuhl du brauchst ordentlichen schreibtisch du brauchst ordentlichen rechen du brauchst ordentlichen monitor du brauchst ordentliches equipment das headset darfst dich nicht so anhören das hast du es gerade im arsch stecken du brauchst ordentliches equipment und die leute die am meisten über homeoffice merken also
ach das ist doch alles nix das sind die leute die das unter den unergonomischen bedingungen daheim machen aber es soll jeder machen wie er will ich habe da wirklich kein problem weil leute sagen sie wollen ins büro gehen sollen sie das machen das ist das in ordnung was ich was ich doof finde ist was ich doof finde ist wenn da irgendwelche etwas älteren manager generationen der meinung sind sie wüssten jetzt was das beste ist für alle leute sie wissen ja noch nicht mal
was das beste für die firma ist das ist tatsächlich der wahnsinn was bei uns teilweise für entscheidungen getroffen werden da greife ich mir echt an kopf man hat es auch oft genug gesehen dass es in die hose geht also ich weiß nicht ob es bei uns eine wie nennt man das wie nennt man so was richtig performance analyse glaube ich heißt das von managerarbeit gibt kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen
was da teilweise entschieden wird und was da halt teilweise für geld durch die lappen geht weil irgendwelche krummen also es ist es ist echt der wahnsinn ich sag nicht dass ich das prinzipiell besser könnte dass wir das will das will ich gar nicht sagen aber manche dinger sind so offensichtlicher schwachsinn und sind auch schon oft genug nach hinten losgegangen wo ich mich immer frage wie schaffen die das eigentlich ist das so krass schön zu reden immer naja egal achja das ist das
auch so ein ding es gibt es gibt viele es gibt viele berufe und oder geht das vielleicht nicht so richtig aber ich bin da an sich gerade was das thema home office angeht es gibt viele berufe da geht es wenn beide beide seiten wollen ja also zum beispiel wenn man jetzt als handwerker arbeitet klar wenn jetzt vor ort irgendwo hinfahren muss und da in die wand verputzen oder oder zauen bauen oder keine ahnung dann kannst du das natürlich nicht von daheim aus machen aber wenn du irgendwelche
rechnungsgeschichten machen muss fortbildungs sachen was auch immer ich bin kein handwerker ich weiß es nicht genau gibt bestimmt die möglichkeit wenn man das ordentlich organisiert die leute das selbst wollen unter chef das will dass die auch den ein oder anderen tag home office machen könnten bin ich mir sicher dass das funktioniert wenn alle wollen du würdest gern mein zimmer als home office anlasse naja wahrscheinlich hast du ja schon alles du brauchst ordentlichen monitor du brauchst ordentlichen rechner du brauchst ordentlichen schreibtisch tastatur stuhl also
im prinzip alles das was die leute eh schon haben die relativ viel online machen ja man solltest es vielleicht nicht auf dem klo oder in der küche oder im wohnzimmer auf dem sofa machen weil da kann man nicht gescheit arbeiten du brauchst eine tür die du zumachen kannst am besten die tür auch die du abschließen kannst wenn du nervige leute hast das war's gescheites headset ansonsten brauchst du ja nichts ja übrigens ich habe es jetzt auf der arbeit überredet soweit endlich endlich habe
ich geschafft ich kriege jetzt eine jährliche jährliche jetbrains rider license aktuell verwende ich meine private ich habe jetzt lang genug erzählt was ja auch so ist dass ich halt nicht gescheit arbeiten kann ohne ide und wir haben uns jetzt endlich beantragt dass ich wenn es ja nicht so dass es teuer wäre 139 euro was was juckt das denn
ja endlich kriege ich jetzt ordentliche lizenz kann ich auf der arbeit auch gescheit dort net proger progerman machen ich sage aktuell verwende ich meine private lizenz aber
ja die meisten also die ganzen java hacker mans bei uns verwenden intellijay aber intellijay kostet nix rider kostet was intellijay ist ja so quasi das das jebait angebot von jetbrains um dir zu zeigen wie cool jetbrains ist
ich glaube ich glaube pie charm ist auch kostenlos oder ist pie charm nicht auch kostenlos ruby mine gibt es immer noch keck weight also pie charm community ist kostenlos und ich glaube intellijay ist auch kostenlos aber der rest kostet was
egal so mit akku sync wie gesagt ich hatte immer sync master also wenn ich den arm von ihm sehe ich weiß nicht wie er ausschaut aber wenn ich den arm von ihm sehe ich würde vermuten dass der auch ein bisschen
pepo fett ist dass der sieht wahrscheinlich umgeformt das sieht ein bisschen aus wie mein arm wie siehts bei dir mit vr brillen aus habe ich nix weil ich hab ich hab nix weil es gibt nix was ich mit vr brillen machen will außer half life spielen
und nur für half life finde ich lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht warum soll ich 500 euro ausgeben für irgendwie dann oder noch mehr für den set up ja um dann ein spiel zu spielen
vr porn zwar ich wusste es ich wusste es dass jetzt irgendeiner mit vr porn um die ecke kommte wir skippen mal ein bisschen vor
so ich weiß es ist immer malIMM YOUR equilibrium der gamriele leit backlash hier ja auch krass
1600 x 1200 glaube ich, oder?
4 zu 3 resolutions, kurz gucken
Videobrock
List of common resolutions, hier zeig mal her. Aha
Was haben wir hier? Wow, alter Wikipedia ist wieder zu 5-Head für mich. 1600 x 1200, ja
Aber da steht nicht, was 4 zu 3 ist. Das ist mir zu 5-Head das Ding. Also
1600 x 1200 war das glaube ich. Ja 4 zu 3, genau ja.
UXGA heißt das. Das war mir so nicht bewusst, dass ich damals in UXGA gespielt habe.
Das schwarz war doch auch echt. Naja das schwarz von einem CRT war insofern echt, weil einfach
kein Licht da war und dementsprechend war der Pixel halt aus. CRT hattest du ja im Endeffekt
vorne. Warte mal, ich guck mal ob man das hier sieht. Du hast ja bei einem CRT, du hast ja vorne
ein relativ großer Glaskörper. Dahinter hast du so eine Schicht aus, ist das irgendwie das Phosphor
oder so? Keine Ahnung. Irgendwas was leuchtet, wenn man das anschießt mit Elektronen. Und
ich weiß nicht mal genau wie der Kram funktioniert hat. Diese Phosphorschicht wird hier von hinten
angeschossen, dann leuchtet der Pixel, der leuchtet aber nur ganz kurz, deswegen muss der Strahl halt
hier rumwandern und das immer wieder neu anleuchtet. Das heißt wenn der schwarz ist und der Pixel nicht
angeleuchtet wird, dann ist es schwarz, weil dann leuchtet der Pixel halt nicht. Du hast
so einen Elektronenstrahl, der saust hier wie verrückt über alle Zeilen des Monitors drüber,
von links oben nach rechts unten und dann fängt er wieder oben an. Daher kommt übrigens auch der
Name Vsync bzw. Refresh Rate, weil das wirklich die Rate ist, in der das hier gebraucht hat von
einmal oben links nach einmal unten rechts und wieder von oben nach oben links. Vsync nicht,
Vsync ist ein bisschen verkehrt. Aber diese ganze Refresh Rate Geschichte kommt daher. Refresh Rates
in dem Sinne, wie es heute bei TFT-Monitoren und sowas gibt, ist ja was ganz anderes als das,
wie es hier bei einem CRT war. Bei einem CRT wurde ja wirklich, du musstest das Bild refreshen,
sonst hättest du gar kein Bild gesehen. Dementsprechend war halt auch schwarz-schwarz,
weil das wurde einfach nicht refreshed. Und beim TFT ist es ja so, hast du einmal eingestellt,
dann bleibt das Bild so. Also für dieses Standbild muss mein CRT theoretisch nix machen.
Mein Schwachsinn, mein TFT, nix machen. So, für das Standbild muss das nix machen.
Ein CRT müsste die ganze Zeit das Bild refreshen, das ist das, was ich sehe.
Oh, das ist aber richtig oldschool. Kennt noch jemand, wenn man Monitor degaust hat? Das kennen
nur oldschool Leute, wissen wie man Monitore degaust. Ah jawoll, schöner VGA. Degaust habe
ich glaube ich schon mal gezeigt, aber ich finde es immer. CRT degaust. Passt mal auf hier. Jetzt
wird degaust. Wo macht der das? Alter, was macht der denn da? Ah, jawoll, das da.
Das da meine ich. Das da meine ich. Ja, weil das Ding von magnetischen Einflüssen hast du,
vielleicht kennt das noch jemand, wenn jemand mal Lautsprecher neben seinem Monitor stehen hatte.
Bisschen größere Lautsprecher, da sind ja Magnete drin in Lautsprechern. Und dann hat man sich
gewundert, warum der Monitor teilweise so Kreise auf der Seite hatte. Das lag daran, weil die
Magnete in dem Lautsprecher den Strahl hier vom CRT abgelenkt haben. Manchmal ist das hängen
geblieben und du musstest das dann weit genug weg machen und einmal degausen. Dann war das wieder
gut. Ja, gut, was auch immer. Degaust. Max, hast du früher Text-only-Monitore erlebt? Du meinst
Text-only-Betriebssysteme von den Monitoren? Was der Monitor anzeigt ist dem egal. Oder meinst du
noch so Oldschool Text-Interface-Überdrucker? Das Ding wiegt wahrscheinlich 20 Kilo oder so.
Viel zu neu, das ist schon Pentium 3. Das hier. Oh hier, das wichtigste Tool damals. Demon Tools.
Da konnte man Isos mounten unter Windows. Demon Tools, Leute, ich sag's euch. Natürlich,
natürlich, natürlich nur rein für, rein für legale Zwecke verwendet, Demon Tools.
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen. Jawoll. Ah, Alter, hör mal auf Solitär. Was ist das?
SimTower oder irgendwie sowas? Ja, nice, nice. YouTube, letzte Chance gescheite Videos
vorzuschlagen. Nope, hat keinen Bock. Clone CD war auch, also ich kann mich nur noch an
Demon Tools erinnern, erinnern. Demon Tools Light war das, genau. Das hatten wir für Windows
damals, für Isos. Und dann gab es noch, wie hieß das Ding zum CD brennen? Nero oder so
gab es dann noch. Weil das Problem war, wenn du damals CDs gebrannt hast, wenn du die CD,
also du konntest die CD nicht abbrechen, das Ding war nicht, das Ding war nicht, war nicht
advanced genug. Ja, das mit der Flamme, genau. So, zumindest wenn du damals eine CD gebrannt
hast, bei den alten Laufwerken und bei den Kackrechnern und bei Windows 8 und so, du
konntest das nicht wieder, du konntest das nicht wieder aufnehmen. Das heißt, du musstest
den Rechner anmachen, musstest sagen, hey brenn jetzt was und du, du hast im Prinzip
immer die, die Hand hochnehmen müssen und so nach dem Motto, ich mach jetzt nichts, dass
es nicht abgekackt ist. So, und dann gab es dann teilweise Software, die hat angefangen,
das quasi zu buffern, dass du nicht so leicht deinen Brennvorgang schrotten konntest. Und
später hat es so Laufwerke, die das konnten. Dann gab es dann irgendwann sogar CDRW und
solche abgedrehten Dinger. Ultra ISO, das kenne ich nicht mehr, ich kann mich nur an
Demon Tools erinnern. Was ist das? Alter, was, 33 Pfund, was sind denn das? V.a. welche
Pound to Kilogramm? 15, ja die Hälfte ungefähr, 15. 15 Kilogramm Katze, Alter, meine wiegt
glaube ich 5 Kilo oder so und die ist auch jetzt nicht die aller, also Chico ist jetzt
auch nicht die aller dünnste, die wiegt glaube ich irgendwie 5 Kilo. Aber, Alter, Chonker,
richtig huge Chonker. Alter, ist die fett. Warum baden Leute ihre Katze, kann mir das
mal irgendjemand erklären? Das ist total unsinnig die Katze zu baden. Ok, vielleicht
den dicken, weil der nicht mehr überall hinkommt. Aber, man muss seine Katze nicht baden. Um
die sauber zu machen, Katze machen sich selbst sauber, du musst die Katze nicht baden. Jawoll.
Oh, das sind die China Mäuse, die habe ich auch. Ja, er ist wirklich viel dünner, guck
mal hier, das ist ja kaum noch die selbe Katze. Also meine Katze, die erste hier, die ich
hatte, die Original Katze FPS, die war quasi fast nur draußen und ich musste die nicht
einmal baden. Wozu? Das einzige was mir einfallen würde ist, in dem Fall wenn die Katze vielleicht
so fett ist, dass sie selbst nicht mehr machen könnte oder, dass die in irgendwas klebriges
reingefallen ist oder so, was sie halt sonst nicht abbekommt. Oder in Farbe oder in irgendwas,
keine Ahnung. Aber das passiert ja selten. Ok, aber normalerweise musst du das nicht
machen. Ja. Alter, was ein bigger Sack. Aber jetzt, aber jetzt, guck mal hier. Ja. Ok,
Flöhe und Krankheiten, ja ok, das ergibt Sinn, das vielleicht auch noch. Aber normalerweise
musst du deine Katze nicht baden. Die machen das schon. Die sind ja nicht umsonst einen
halben Tag damit beschäftigt, sich so abzulecken. Ok, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Hacking Nintendo
Wii, R.I.T. Commands, Old Servers, Battlefield, ah komm, wir gucken uns ne Runde. Ne, wir
gucken uns ne Runde, Battlefield 3, Leute an, die nicht die zwei linke Hände beim Spielen
haben. Moment, ist das ne P90 mit Codra Visier? Das ist auch mal was abgedreht, na gut, warum
nicht noch? Werden sie weggesprayt. Leider ist Venice dead, die haben es halt ein bisschen
verkackt. Alter, die lassen sich aber wieder bashen. Wisst ihr was das Gude an Battlefield
3 ist? Dass Battlefield 3 nur noch PC Clips sind. Niemand spielt mehr Battlefield 3 auf
der Konsole. Das heißt, wenn du Clips siehst, sind die im Prinzip immer zu 99% vom PC und
dementsprechend haben es gescheite Quali. BF4 sieht anders aus. Richtiges Pepegas, Alter.
Richtiges Pepega Gegner. Ah, er wieder. Man kann nicht mal sein Venice Account löschen.
Gut, das wird mich jetzt nicht so interessieren, dass man das löschen kann, aber gibt halt
keine Server, ne? Komm, wir gucken mal, wir gucken mal kurz. Lass mal gucken. Azubi 2.2
MP4. Ah, das ist das Video. Das habe ich mal Probe gezeigt, das können wir löschen.
So, mal gucken. Wir können mal raten, wir können mal raten, wie viel der vollste Server
hat. Ich tippe mal auf drei Leute. Wobei es ist Sonntagmorgen, es ist Sonntagmorgen.
Vielleicht sind es auch sechs Leute. Einer, einer. Einer, nice. Richtig, Poggers. Ah,
wieder mit seinem Smoke, Smoke Launcher. Jetzt wird wieder, jetzt wird wieder rumgesprayt,
jawoll. Bäm, bäm, bäm. Rex Beste, Alter. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie viele Stunden
er hat. Er hat bestimmt auch schon 6000 Stunden Battlefield 3 oder so. Wow, dass er den getroffen
hat, hat er schon gedacht. Oh, wie ist es nicht checken, Alter? Wie ist es nicht checken?
Ah, Mist, Mist. Das hätte einen nice Clip geben können nochmal, also noch viel besserer.
Warum, warum ich glaube, warum Venice gefloppt ist, ähm, mehrere Gründe. Erstens, ja nicht,
es hat zwar ein bisschen, bisschen Aufmerksamkeit generiert, aber nicht, nicht genug. Also auch
ein bisschen Marketingtechnik, nicht so gut, nicht so gut gemacht. Man hätte bestimmt
auch mehr große Streamer nicht draufsetzen müssen, dass sie das schon machen, sondern
auch mal aktiv anschreiben, also Streamer und YouTube Leute und so. Äh, irgendwie da
mal aktiv den Kontakt suchen. Und das Wichtigste, woran, also wovon ich von ausgehe, dass das
größte, größte Punkt, warum Venice gescheitert ist, es gab keine offiziellen Server. Du hättest
offizielle Server haben müssen, die, die auf einer Version sind, die funktioniert. Noch
viel wichtiger, die gescheit administriert moderiert sind, äh, und die nicht zu weit
weg sind vom originalen Battlefield 3, aber die Vorzüge von Venice zeigen. Zum Beispiel,
man könnte, man könnte einen offiziellen Rush und einen offiziellen Conquest Server
machen können und darauf hätte man zum Beispiel die Mods für den Blaufilter drauf machen
können, man hätte Mods drauf machen können, dass Engineerwaffen von Medics verwendet werden
können und so. So leichte Anpassungen, die das Game irgendwie neu und frisch machen,
man hätte ein cooles Procressionsystem machen können und, und all solche Dinger, ähm,
aber das steht und verhält halt mit offiziellen Support und offiziellen Servern, was es halt
nicht gegeben hat. Du hattest nix, was du gescheit spielen konntest, du hattest irgendwelche
Server, wo der Admin selbst gehackt hat. Das will ja keiner drauf spielen. Matrix sagt
dir, danke für den Sub, 13 auch hier, 15 Monate, nee 23 Monate, huge Hype als Subscription.
Ja, und die letzten, des letzten Rest an Spiele haben sie sich gekillt, weil sie nen Memory
Leak hatten, dass du nach zwei Runden, äh, gecrashed bist oder nach zwei Minuten oder
was auch immer. Weiß nicht, ob sie das je wieder gefixt haben, aber RIP.
Ja, nicht nur Cheating, Admins cheaten den Serverbesitzer, das kann ja nicht sein. In
der S gesniped kriegen sie und so Check-Ins nicht. Oh, der war nice, der war nice, dass
er den noch erwischt hat. Dank Suppression auch Glück gehabt, dass das funktioniert hat.
Battlefield 3 Suppression, das wissen wir noch. Ohohohoho, Collet Relics, nice, nice.
Okay, der zweite war schon sehr, sehr glücklich. Alter, die Schneiber-Action. Ist das, ist
das 360? Das ist Xbox Gameplay, oder? Das sieht so kantig aus, das ist bestimmt Xbox
Gameplay. Nee, Moment, da oben, das ist PC, das ist PC, da ist sonst weder keine Frame-Anzeige,
das ist die Debug-Frame-Anzeige, das ist PC. Aber was zum Teufel ist das für ein PC?
Sieht aus wie Xbox 360, wahrscheinlich ist ein PC aus der Ära, oder? Wer? Logitech?
Ja gut, Katzenbilder zählen wir immer. Welches Headset ich empfehle fürs Homeoffice, das ist
egal, irgendwas mit gescheiter Mikrofonqualität. Das geht alles Mögliche. Ich habe immer meinen
Mix 300 auf, das gleiche wie jetzt auch. Naja, komm, also so geil ist der Clip jetzt nicht.
Moment, vielleicht kommt jetzt noch was. Oh, das ist nice. Das fühlt sich voll an wie Konsolen-Gameplay,
aber es ist kein Konsolen-Gameplay. Es macht schon ein paar nice Shots jetzt. Auf der Arbeit
habe ich dieses Wireless Bluetooth Headset, wo ich festgestellt habe, dass das sogar ein
Mikrofon hat. Aber hier daheim verwende ich meinen MMX300. Ja, das kannst du auch machen.
Du kannst aber separat das Mikro und Kopfhörer holen. Das ist ja das, was ich auch immer empfohlen
habe in der Vergangenheit. Aber wenn man unbedingt eine Headset-Kombi haben will, sage ich mal so,
das MMX300 ist wunderbar. Es kostet halt was. Also wenn du preisleistungsmäßig was haben willst,
was qualitativ besser ist als jedes Headset, wobei es da mittlerweile durchaus ein paar brauchbare
gibt, dann hol dir ein Mikrofon und Kopfhörer. Allerdings kann ich es aufgrund der Handhabung
nachvollziehen, wenn man sagt, man möchte ein Headset haben. Weil selbst wenn man sich so was,
Kopfhörer mit irgendein Mod-Mick holt, die aktuellen Mod-Micks sind ja auch nicht billig.
Wie machst du das im Homeoffice mit der Hardware? Sag ich gleich was zu.
Was hat der für ein Lack? Der hat die Scheibe gemessert und das hat drei Sekunden gedauert.
AN490 in your face. Warum spielen die alle in so ultra niedriger Auflösung? Ist das irgendwie,
ist das irgendwie, muss man das als Battlefield Pro machen, irgendwie in 1280 x 720 spielen?
Oder ist das einfach nur, weil die Rechner so kacke sind?
Das WNCS größere Hitboxen 4 zu 3. Würde sich da einfach mal eine umdrehen von den Typen, ja?
Next up, a clip from MadKorean using the AEK 971. Again, he manages to find a bunch of
enemy players that I think any of us would have an easy time taking out, but I guess this is what
happens when you're really good at positioning. You just get into those great positions and those
great spots to put together these killstreets.
Das ist was, was mich in Battlefield 3 immer richtig genervt hat, wenn das Wiederbeleben
nicht funktioniert. In Battlefield 3 backt das Wiederbeleben ja teilweise rum, wenn Midi-Kids
davor steht oder aber wenn die irgendwie halb hinter was liegen oder sonst wie. Da war mir
das Bad Company 2 Wiederbeleben fast besser, da konntest du ja sogar die Wand wiederbeleben.
Alles was in der Nähe war, konntest du wiederbeleben. Was ist mit euch los? Die stehen immer noch da,
die stehen immer noch da. Warum switcht ihr nicht auf die Pistole? Was ist mit euch los? Alter,
ist das, ist das, haben die das gefaked oder was? Das kannst du sowas, sowas hast du doch
normalerweise nicht. Metro in 2042 Confirmed? Nee, glaub nicht. Aber, aber Nose-Hair-Candles
ist Confirmed in 2042. Dann holst du es dir nicht. Wer möchte nicht, wer möchte nicht
Metro 64 vs. 64 Metro B Flagge haben? 24 7 5000 Tickets. Rote Dreiecke, das ist halt das
Problem an Smoke in Battlefield 3. Ja, ich finde also gegen gute Defender ist Metro wirklich
schwierig? Alle, alle Punkte eigentlich. Die sind alles so blind. Aber M416, beste, beste
Waffe hier. Hab ich glaub ich die meisten Spielstunden mit. Warte mal, Big Shack, weil ich mich da
gerade draufkomme. Hat er, hat er wieder was, was Neues? Big Shack. Ich weiß ja, dass der
Typ bevor mich jetzt wieder irgendeiner aufklärt und sagte, Max, aber eigentlich heißt, ich
weiß, dass es eigentlich glaube ich ein britischer Comedy-Mann ist und dass das ja einfach quasi
als Verarschung gedacht war, diese ganze Big Shack-Geschichte. Aber es war trotzdem irgendwie
mal was anderes. Ich fand das, ich fand das lustig. Quickmaps. Also 2042 gibt's, gibt's
Norscher wieder. Bin mal gespannt, wann denn dieses Event ist. Ich darf nicht, wie gesagt,
ich darf jetzt zwar nichts, nichts genaues erzählen, aber es gibt noch, es gibt wohl
noch mal einen, noch mal die Möglichkeit für gewisse Content-Creators im Vorfeld das Spiel
anzuspielen und ich hoffe mal, ich erfahre bald wann das ist.
Ich sag gleich was zu der Homeoffice-Frage, wenn das fertig ist, ist er gleich durch.
Ja gut, das war jetzt halt so, das war jetzt ein Norscher Run & Gun Clip. So, also, hier,
Homeoffice wollte ich was zu sagen. Also, und zwar, ähm, das liegt daran, dass das
noch durch ein paar OBS-Settings geht. Also, ich hab das erste Mal an einem gescheiten
Audio-Interface dran, mein MMX300. So, dann hab ich's hier auf 71% stehen, aber das liegt
halt daran, wie das Audio-Interface eingestellt ist. So, und hier hab ich dieses RTX-Voice-Lite,
was nicht wirklich RTX-Voice ist, aber in die ähnliche Richtung geht. Noisegate, dass
es sich ausschaltet, wenn ich nix sag. Ein bisschen noch den Gain geboostet und Kompressors-Settings,
die ich irgendwo aus dem Internet hab. So, easy, fertig. So, warte mal, wo war das denn,
Hardware? Also, ja genau, also, wie machst du das mit, äh, wie machst du das im Homeoffice
mit der Hardware? Du hast ein Notebook von der Arbeit und ein Docking-Station mit KVM.
Ne, also, bei uns ist es relativ zum Glück, relativ einfach. Und zwar, ich setz mich morgens
an den gleichen Rechner, wo ich jetzt hier auch bin. Ich hab mir nur den eigenen Windows-Account
gemacht für Homeoffice. Ich will ja nicht den Recording-Ordner aus Versehen mal liegen
in einem Teams-Meeting. Ne, ich hab meinen eigenen Account gemacht und ich setz am gleichen
Rechner. Ich hab links nen Monitor, rechts nen Monitor. Und wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten,
wie man sich verbinden kann. Man kann sich entweder über, äh, nen Browser verbinden,
da gibt es so nen, so nen Windows-Remote-Portal, was aber ziemlich sackt, weil es laggy as
fuck ist. Oder es gibt die Möglichkeit über VPN. Wobei die Möglichkeit über VPN jetzt
mittlerweile relativ stark beschnitten ist. Und, äh, daraufhin ich jetzt an einigen Stellen
rumgemerkt hab, dass ich nicht mehr arbeiten kann. Mal gucken, was da rauskommt. Ja, und
für meine Progas-Geschichten hab ich ne Ubuntu-VM, wo ich mich dann verbinde. Aus der hab ich
dann auch immer VPN gemacht. VPN auf Privat? Warum nicht? Was ist der Unterschied? Glaubt
ihr, also gibt es wirklich irgendjemand, der glaubt, dass Leute mit RUT zugängen, in
irgendeiner Art und Weise auf ihren privaten Rechner schlechter aufpassen können als auf
den, auf das Firmen-Notebook? Oder dass das die Firmen-Admins irgendwie besser können
als, äh, als die Leute selbst? Das halt ich für ein Gerücht. Ey, ich seh da überhaupt
kein Problem. Zumal ja auch überall auf der Welt Bring-Your-Own-Device immer aktueller
wird. Ja, die glauben das. Ey, es gibt sicherlich Leute, da ist das so. Es gibt sicherlich,
es gibt sicherlich Leute, da ist das wirklich so. Ja, die können das nicht. Aber ich hab
da keine Schmerzen mit. Ich komm ja mit meinem VPN-Zugang auch nirgendswohin. Also, wenn ich
mit meinem VPN-Zugang wirklich auf irgendwelche Produktivsysteme will, da muss ich mich, lass
mal überlegen. Was muss ich denn machen? Ich brauch VPN, zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Ich brauch Login, zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung. Ich brauch, ähm, ja, wie soll man das nennen?
Ähm, Admin Zugang, Zwischenstells, zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung. Also, man kann's, ich brauch zwei Mal, ich
brauch drei Mal zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung, dass ich überhaupt irgendwo drauf bin, dass
ich auch nur dran denken kann, mich auf ein produktives System zu verbinden. Also, dass
das irgendeiner hijackt, da hab ich so meine Zweifel. Genau, sag ich, sag ich, es kommt
auf die Leute an, ne? Du hast sicherlich Leute, die können das nicht. Da würd ich dann auch
sagen, hey, benutzt mal schön ne Laptop. Ich hätte übrigens auch gar keine Schmerzen
mit, wenn die mir ne Notebook geben würden. Ich würde sogar ne Windows Notebook von der
Arbeit nehmen. Es ist natürlich ein bisschen doof, dass man das hin und her schleppen muss.
Und was macht man, wenn man das nicht mitnimmt, weil man sich denkt, am nächsten Tag kommt
man und dann ist Bahnschreik und kommt nicht. Also, das ist natürlich, ist natürlich ein
bisschen problemarisch. Ich hätte kein Problem. Das Problem ist, was die bei uns nicht schaffen,
ist, mir ne Windows Notebook zu geben, wo alles drauf ist, was ich brauch. Wie gesagt, die
haben es bis jetzt nicht geschafft, mir Rider zu besorgen bzw. zu paketieren. Ich hab sie,
wir sind jetzt erst mal so weit, dass mein Chef überhaupt den Antrag stellen konnte.
Also, dass es gekauft wird, dass es endlich mal durch ist. Du kannst keinem Zero trusten,
das funktioniert nicht. Spätestens deine Admins können deine Datenbank abziehen und
ins Darknet verkaufen, wenn sie wollen. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich mein, man kann, man
kann sagen, man schaut, dass halt leichtsinnige Sachen nicht passieren können. Ja, zum Beispiel
dass man unbekannte USB-Geräte nicht erlaubt oder so. Meinetwegen, ja, das verstehe ich
alles. Ja. Aber das funktioniert nicht. Du hast einfach Leute, die kommen an sensible
Sachen dran und denen musst du trauen, sonst frage ich mir, warum du so einstellst. Zumindest,
wenn du von Anfang an denkst, ich traue ihnen nicht oder irgendwie, sag mal so, wenn du
von Anfang an denkst, ich traue ihnen nicht, ist ja okay. Aber spätestens wenn sie ein
Jahr für dich gearbeitet haben und nie Scheiße gebaut haben, sollte man sich mal langsam
überlegen, okay, ist das sinnvoll. Also, du schaffst das gar nicht. Du hast immer Leute,
die kommen irgendwo drauf, wo relevante Informationen liegen, relevante Daten liegen, die was kaputt
machen könnten, mutwillig irgendwas abziehen könnten, vom ins Darknet verkaufen bis an
die Konkurrenz ab. Die Leute machen das nicht. Was ist denn SY2? Das weiß ich nicht, was
das ist. Brauchst du da Führungszeugnis oder so? Ja, das könnte man vielleicht auch machen,
aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde mir ziemlich doof vorkommen, wenn ich, wenn, wenn, angenommen
ich würde mich irgendwo wirklich nochmal so als Linux-Administrator bewerben und dann
sagt einer zu mir, ich brauche ein Führungszeugnis, dann würde ich mir auch denken, was? Weirdchamp,
Alter. Das ist das in der Taskleiste, das ist ein Terminal. Boah, skip. Was ist SY2?
Unter einer Sicherheitsprüfe versteht man das, okay, also Führungszeugnis oder sowas.
Wohnsitz, Identität, okay, kein Führungszeugnis. Ich habe Half-Life 3 in der Führungs, in
der Taskleiste, genau. Ja, es ist bei uns auch so, auf was ich alles
Admin-Rechte im Endeffekt habe. Ich könnte, wenn ich wollte, quasi für Wochenausfall
sorgen oder Zusatzverdienste im Darknet machen, mache ich aber nicht. Habe ich auch nicht
vor. Also ich verstehe teilweise diese Ultra-Bedenke nicht gegenüber Leuten, denen ihr Job das
ja quasi ist. Was willst du machen? Du wirst nicht darauf
verzichten können, manchen Leuten Rechte für ihre Arbeit geben zu dürfen. Also du
musst manchen Leuten einfach Rechte geben, dass sie ihre Arbeit machen können und umso
restriktiver du bist, umso weniger kannst du agil sein. Das muss ja auch allen klar
sein. Es wird immer erzählt so nach dem Motto, wir sind so super modern und agil. Es ist
ja oftmals einfach nur vorgeschoben, die meisten Leute haben nur nicht mal zwei Sätze gelesen
von diesem Original-Manifest. Ich weiß, ich hatte mal einer von euch reingeguckt, zufälligerweise
hat mal einer von euch jemals in dieses Original-Agile-Paper reingeguckt und wie wenig das überhaupt noch
mit der Realität von heute zu tun hat. Na egal. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau,
also umso restriktiver du bist, umso weniger kannst du agil sein. Das ist ja klar. Also
wenn du beispielsweise sagst, du brauchst für jeden Handschlag ein Formular mit doppeltem
Durchschlag und zwei Augenverfahren und sonst was, dann bist du nicht agil. Das eine und
das andere kann nicht zusammen funktionieren. Du kannst nicht für die simpelsten Sachen
eine halbe Stunde brauchen müssen und dann sagen, das ist agil, das klappt nicht. Ich
mache gerade eine Ausbildung, Fachinformatik, Anwendungsentwicklung, bin kurz vorm Ende,
ich habe eine Übernahme bekommen, möchte trotzdem noch Formatik. Ist das empfehlenswert,
berufsbegleitend zu stehen oder teils hat? Keine Ahnung, kann ich dir leider nichts zu raten. Ich
stelle mir aber ganz ehrlich, es ist ziemlich schwierig vor zu arbeiten und zu studieren. Dann
machst du ja den ganzen Tag nichts anderes. Dann gehst du arbeiten und dann gehst du,
das ist ja, was ich mir eher vorstellen kann, ist duales Studium oder sowas. Aber dass man
berufsbegleitend studieren kann, stelle ich mir sehr ätzend vor. Der Mastercrapper, der Kumpel
vom Friseur und mir aus Dresden, der hat das ja gemacht, da hat er Informatik studiert,
neben seinem normalen Job, aber da ist halt auch erstens Massive, Massive FireQ,
FireFed, aber auch der fand das sehr anstrengend. Du hast eine Studie für Agile Master besucht,
das ist nur für Mikro-Management. Das ist ja der Witz, eigentlich geht es ja bei agilen,
also bei dem ursprünglichen Gedanken von agiler Softwareentwicklung geht es ja darum, möglichst
viele Stonks und Managerleute aus dem Programmierprojekt oder Programmier,
Programmieralltag rauszuwerfen. Das ist ja der eigentliche Sinn hinter diesem agilen Manifest
mal gewesen. Möglichst viele Projektmanager und Stonksleute auszusperren, erst mal zu sagen,
hey, ihr habt die Chance ab und zu was zu dem Projekt zu sagen und das zu steuern,
aber zwischen diesen Schritten, das ist ja der Ursprungsgedanken von diesem ganzen agilen
Stellzeugs hier, aber zwischen diesen Sprints, also zwischen diesen Kontrollierschritten können
die Programmierer machen quasi, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, was sie wollen anhand der Vorgaben,
aber wie das dann gemacht wird und was da wie umgesetzt wird, ist den Programmierern überlassen
und dementsprechend ist die Qualität besser, als wenn jeder Tag sich in irgendeinen Managertyp
was anderes überlegt. Das ist ja eigentlich der Ursprungsgedanke hinter diesem, also die Leute,
die sich das mal ursprünglich ausgedacht haben, hinter diesem ganzen agilen Zeug. Was da heute
draus gemacht wurde, hat damit ja überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun. Ist bei uns auch so. Übrigens,
Antivirus auch witzig, ich hab ne VM, ne offizielle VM, über die wollte ich mal Log-Dateien von nem
Linux-Server, von nem Squid-Server runterkopieren und das ging nicht, der hat immer nach 40 MB
abgebrochen. Bis ich dann dahinter gekommen ist, was das ist, das war unser Antivirus,
der hat gedacht, das ist irgendein Verschlüsselungsangriff oder so, weil viele
Dateien mit Schwachsinns-Inhalt geschrieben wurden. Der Antivirus hat das Kopieren von
Log-Dateien von nem Squid geblockt, weil er gedacht hat, das ist irgendeine Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner-Attacke.
Deswegen konnte ich nur 40 MB Logs kopieren. Das ist alles so fail. Dann beschwert es sich,
warum es nicht funktioniert. Du folgst mir, als du noch ein Cod-Kind warst. Bist du nicht
mehr? Ich bin immer noch Call of Duty Kind. Hört man doch. 360 No Scope, Alter. Was hältst
du von Anti-Viren-Programm? Nix. Aber der Windows Defender kann man schon drauflassen. Aber
zusätzliche Sachen braucht man echt nicht. Seit Black Ops 2? Ja, ich auch. Ich hab die
letzten kaum noch gespielt. Ich hab Modern Warfare mal wieder ein bisschen gespielt,
als es rausgekommen ist und dann ist mir aufgefallen, wie verkackt das Game eigentlich ist vom Flow
her und dass das Game nicht weiß, was es sein will. Hab ich nicht mehr gespielt. Ok,
kommen wir uns an. Hacking Nintendo Wii-Mini. Auf geht's. Hacker-Mans. Und zwar das Trinkel.
Holst du dir das neue Cod? Hat das einen Single-Player? Ich hab mir Black Ops nur wegen dem Single-Player
geholt, das letzte Black Ops. Und ich muss sagen, der Single-Player war nur ok. Die letzte
Mission war kacke. Der Build-Up dazu war ganz ok, aber die Hälfte von der Black Ops
2 Single-Player war kacke. Ein Viertel war gut und ein Viertel war enttäuschend. Ok,
Hacker-Mans, stell's. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es eine Wii-Mini gab. Ich bin so dumm
gewesen, ich hab meine N64 und meine Wii weggeschmissen beim Umzug. Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Die Spiele hab ich noch, aber ich hab die Konsole gedacht, sonst Scheiß brauch ich eh
nie wieder. Ja, stell's euch mal vor. Bisschen leise, oder?
Was? Moment, Moment, ernsthaft? Der Nintendo hat es geschafft, eine Wii-Mini rauszubringen,
die noch schlechter ist, quasi Connectivity-mäßig, als die original Wii? Naja, gut, das ist
Nintendo, aber das ist ja nie. Kifken, 21 Monate, huge subscription. Big brain.
Ja, vor allem, wer will die auch, wozu will man die dann hacken?
Ja, ja, ja, Banner-Bomb und solche Geschichten, die es damals gab. Weiß nicht, ob einer mal,
hat jemand von euch mal eine Wii geflasht, na geflasht ist das falsche Wort, custom channeled?
Ganz am Anfang hast du noch Twilight Princess gebraucht und ein manipulierter Spielstand?
Und du hast damals Twilight Princess geladen, du hast einen manipulierten Spielstand, wo
der Name von deinem Pferd zu lang war und wenn du dann rückwärts zum NPC gelaufen bist,
der den Namen von deinem Pferd ausgesprochen hat, bist du zufälligerweise auf die richtige
Speicheradresse gesprungen, um weiteren Code nachladen zu können, das war so der erste
Wii Hack, danach gab es Banner-Bomb von der SD-Karte, das war dann einfacher.
Lego Indiana Jones ging auch, kann sein, kann sein, ich kenne nur die Twilight Princess Geschichte,
später ging es einfach mit einem manipulierten Bild oder so. Achja und die externe Festplatte
um Spiele nachzuladen für die Wii, die musste immer am unteren linken USB-Port angeschlossen
sein, ansonsten ging das nicht, wahrscheinlich lag das daran, wie die Sachen in Arbeitsspeicher
gemappt sind oder so.
Also
Es braucht eine Internet-Konnektion.
Ohne diese Methoden, die einfach auf der Wii arbeiten,
wären es für Jahre nicht möglich...
Ja, aber ganz davon, abgesehen, wenn man wirklich eine gehackte Wii haben will,
ich meine, der Kram kostet ja nix mehr.
Okay, neu, neu, neu, braucht man das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Gebraucht gibt's das für ein Apfel und ein Ei bei Ebay.
Ja.
Ups, falsches.
Falsches.
Hacker.
Die Hackers.
Ja.
Aha.
Wi-Fi-Time.
Laseratte 10 hat Contributed.
Gut.
Das ist ein sehr technisches Schreiben, wie der Exploit funktioniert.
Fullmetal 5 hat einen Guide auf den Exploit,
wie er entdeckt wurde und wie er verletzt wurde.
Und ich lasse einen Link in der Beschreibung unten.
Aber natürlich testen wir das für uns selbst.
Die Website wehacks.guide
wird euch durchschauen, was ihr tun müsst,
um den Blubomb-Exploit auf einer Wii-Mini zu machen.
Kann ich danach da eine externe Platte anschließen?
Weil ansonsten ist es ja eigentlich ziemlich sinnig, unsinnig.
Richtig pro wäre es natürlich,
wenn ich danach einen USB-Hub anschließen könnte
mit Platte und einem Bluetooth-Adapter für das Internet.
Aber das wird nicht funktionieren.
Pi.
Moment.
Hat der Raspberry Pi nicht Bluetooth selbst mit drauf?
Hat er nicht selbst Bluetooth drauf?
Warum brauche ich da einen Bluetooth-Adapter?
Alle halbwegs aktuellen...
Das ist auch ein neuer.
Guck mal, der hat blaue USB-Ports.
Das ist ein vierer.
Der hat doch Bluetooth drauf.
Virtual Machine on Windows or similar,
but something like a Raspberry Pi with a Boon2 also works.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
...that supports this adapter.
You could easily install a Linux Virtual Machine on Windows or similar,
but something like a Raspberry Pi with a Boon2 also works.
Der spricht das falsch aus.
Wir wissen alle, dass Chubantu heißt.
...works and this was my preferred method.
So, to set all this up,
first we download the HackMe installer
and copy it to a USB flash drive
and then insert that into the back of the Wii Mini.
This installer contains the homebrew channel...
Okay, okay.
Also, USB-Stick...
...for running homebrew on any Wii...
...in the Wii.
...and the Wii Mini is no different.
Then on the Raspberry Pi simply download the script
that will set up the Blue Bomb exploit.
Run it and enter the information
it's asking about your Wii Mini.
In my case, it's USA
and NTSC.
Once you've entered everything,
the script will then idle
with the message waiting to accept.
...
Fernbedienungs-Discovery und der Raspberry Pi tut halt so, als wäre er eine Wii-Fernbedienung
und nutzt dann halt in dieser Bluetooth-Kommunikation zwischen vermeintlicher Fernbedienung und
Wii nutzt er halt irgendwelche Big-Brain-Sachen aus.
At this point we have successfully hacked the Wii Mini.
And now the Hack-Me-Loader will run and bring up a familiar screen.
And from here we can install the homebrew channel.
On a regular Wii we would also install Boot-Me, but this needs SD card support.
And that's obviously not included on the Wii Mini, so we must skip over this.
So what can you do with a hacked Nintendo Wii Mini?
Nix.
Well it turns out, quite a lot.
Nicht wirklich was ohne internet Zugang, oder?
Na gut, vorbei, vorbei, was brauchst du, die meisten Sachen sind ja eh heute down.
And this of course will allow for all unsigned homebrew apps and games.
And from here I recommend installing Preloader and following the guide to protect from any
bricking of the system, which of course is very important.
And from here, well, it's up to you.
But I recommend installing D2X and installing C-IOS to allow games to run from USB either
via using Wii Flow or the USB Loader.
Now one of the more interesting apps that I recommend you take a look at once you've homebrew
modded your Nintendo Wii Mini is the CleanRip, and this is something that I would recommend
on any Wii system, and that offers the ability to take your physical media and insert it
into the disk drive, and then allows you to rip your games directly.
Ja, ich habe selbstverständlich jegliche Games, die ich über den Emulator gespielt
habe, nur so kopiert.
Ich habe mir nie ROMs runtergeladen.
On to your USB stick.
Now remember, we don't have access to the SD card slot on the Wii Mini, but we still
have access to the Wii USB.
Now it does take about 25 minutes or so to rip one of the games to disk, but you can essentially
back up your entire Wii Game collection onto USB, and if you have access to a large USB
drive, then you can take your external USB drive and the Wii Mini with you on the road
and have access to all the Wii games without having to bring your collection with you.
The Wii Mini frustratingly has no ethernet support as we mentioned, but this can also
be enabled with the Ethernet Enabler App by 4Metal5, and this allows the Wii Mini to connect
to the internet via ethernet cable.
It's meant to run once and injects an ethernet configuration into the system settings, something
that can normally not be done with the Wii Mini system menu, and this is pretty awesome
stuff.
But perhaps the final omission on the Wii Mini that can be enabled, and I think is the
coolest feature, is the back compat with GameCube Games.
The tool, known as Nintendont, will handle this for us.
Nintendont isn't an emulator, rather it takes advantage of the Wii's hardware, which is
effectively an overclocked GameCube, while Nintendo removed the ability to read and load
GameCube disks.
There is no way that they could remove GameCube support, and this is a reason why you can
use Nintendont on the Wii U.
In any case, Nintendont works really well.
Obviously you lose the ability to use GameCube controllers as the hardware doesn't support
them, but GameCube games run fine from USB and you can still use your Wii controllers.
I mentioned that the Wii has a really great and established homebrew scene, and the choices
are really there with what you want to play.
For me, I recommend loading up on emulators such as the excellent Genesis GX Plus, a fantastic
emulator for Genesis, Sega CD and Master System emulator.
You'll have an absolutely wonderful time with this.
Ich meine, wenn ich irgendwas emulieren will, kann ich das auf dem PC wahrscheinlich immer
noch am besten machen.
Oder im Zweifelfall über das Shield TV im Wohnzimmer.
Aber es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Sobald man площadig tenho einen
入туet, kann man es einfach abdominal fassen.
Man kann also unseren proofle Mi kalo
was war meistens ein Kollektorstück für einige und wertlos für viele andere,
hat endlich etwas Wicht und Zweck, dank der Homebrew- und Marding-Kommunikation.
Wenn du dein eigenes Wii-Mini hacken willst,
werde ich alle Links in der Beschreibung unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Aber jetzt lassen wir es hier für diese Episode.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Vergesst nicht zu liken und zu abonnieren.
Thank you for all the support on...
Back in 2019, I made a video series about security and the Xbox 360.
In Part 1, we covered DVD security.
Ich finde die Aussprache von der Xbox immer so geil.
In Deutschland, wir haben immer gesagt, Xbox 360.
So, und die Arme sind immer Xbox 360.
Das klingt irgendwie gleich viel Kokonaiger.
To secure the Xbox 360 after the failures of the original Xbox.
Its custom hardware, Hypervisor, E-Fuses and encryption keys
would be a significant step up from the PC based original Xbox motherboard design.
But hackers realized the challenge to defeat the Hypervisor...
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass die CPU von der Xbox 360
und der Playstation 3 von den gleichen Leuten entwickelt wurde?
...significant. So they initially focused on the DVD drive
with the goal, if we can make the drive believe that a backup copy of an Xbox 360 game is real,
then there is no need to defeat the Hypervisor.
In Part 1 of my series, I discussed the history of DVD exploits
and how they came to be, which would become a cat and mouse game.
Die hatten ja auf der Xbox 360, die haben sich ja jahrelang gefragt,
wie die die ganzen gemordeten Konsolen erkannt haben.
Und das war ja irgendwas auf den CD's drauf.
Sind Xbox und PS3 nicht auch x86? Nee.
Xbox ist PowerPC und Playstation 3 ist Cell, das ist was ganz anderes.
...Game between Microsoft and developer Commodore Forever,
who always seemed to be one step ahead, releasing custom DVD drive firmwares
that worked around almost every obstacle Microsoft presented,
including Stealth Media Chucks, Xbox Live Band, newer anti-piracy and DVD formats.
But inside that timeline, there was one hack that we didn't mention specifically
and quite possibly the craziest console hack ever.
Warum machen die das Ding kaputt?
Because Microsoft would tie in security on the Xbox 360, major components of the hardware would all use per console keys unique to each hardware device and the DVD drive would be no exception.
Microsoft knew that flashing a custom firmware on the DVD drive would expose their security.
So instead, they would encrypt the firmware via the DVD drive keys
and flashing a custom firmware required extracting those keys, which would also be required to rebuild a custom firmware and re-flashing.
In order to re-flash a firmware, the drive would need to be unlocked,
or in other words, putting the drive into a mode where it can be queried and flashed.
And finally, they would also protect the drive from being flashed by setting the flash as read-only.
But unfortunately for Microsoft, getting access to the drive's flash would be one of the very earliest methods to defeat security.
DVD drive mods became quite popular because they were easy to perform.
The DVD drive flash would be on a separate chip on the board, and although Microsoft tried different methods to obfuscate it,
including setting the chip in resin so it could not easily have its pins exposed,
the drive was defeated and custom firmwares were made available.
But in 2012, Microsoft would get creative.
Xbox 360 Slim models had replaced the earlier FAT models, and they knew that they had to do something about the flash chip on the DVD board.
So in certain drives, they would combine the DVD flash chip with the onboard controller, or DSP, into one package.
This package would also be write-protected, which would mean that it would not be possible to flash a custom firmware onto this drive.
Also, Microsoft thought.
One of the most popular DVD drives on the Xbox 360 Slim would be the Leiton DG16D4S.
This drive would contain a Mediatek SoC, which combined the flash and DSP chip into one package.
The flash chip was pre-installed and its mode set to write-only, so it couldn't easily be flashed.
And for good measure, the Mediatek chip would be encased in epoxy resin.
Microsoft thought.
Da hat's Microsoft aber echt gut gemeint, oder?
Guck mal, es gibt ein komplett eigenes Ökosystem an Speedrun-Turnieren für A Link to the Past und für Super Mario, weil für N64 sonst was.
Wobei N64 die spielen auf der Originalkonsole, aber diese ganzen Randomizer-Mods und sowas, das geht natürlich nur vom Emulator.
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Zumal ich es dann immer witzig finde, wenn manche Fanprojekte besser sind als die Sachen von Nintendo selbst.
Letztendlich ist Nintendo auch nicht dafür da, um die Fans glücklich zu machen, sondern für Stonks.
Das hat ja bei Blizzard auch eine Weile gebraucht, bis die Leute das gecheckt haben, dass Blizzard nicht nett ist,
sondern Blizzard einfach nur Stonks machen will, egal was Sache ist.
Und es da schon lange nicht mehr irgendwie um die Fans geht.
Natürlich labern die alle rum nach dem Motto, wir haben die größten besten Fans, solange sie Geld ausgeben.
Und Blizzard und Nintendo auch, denen geht es nie um irgendwelche Sachen, denen geht es immer nur um sich selbst.
Ich glaube, das haben mittlerweile gerade bei Blizzard auch die letzten Leute verstanden,
wobei es immer noch so ein paar Hardcore-Verteidiger gibt.
Ich glaube, dass das genug sein würde, um die DVD-Hackern in ihren Tracks tot zu werden.
Wenn man sich dieses Event als einziges anguckt, könnte man sagen, Blizzard, das sind ja eine Firma aus den USA,
die fanden das wichtig zu unterstützen und standen dahinter und wollten das supporten.
Okay, soweit so gut. Wäre ich auch noch mitgegangen, aber dann kam danach, oder umgedreht,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was zuerst war, dann kam dieser Vorfall mit dem Hearthstone-Spieler aus Hongkong,
der gesagt hat, free Hongkong oder so was, wo dann das Preisgeld eingezogen wurde von einem Jahr,
er von Turnieren gebannt wurde und die Caster rausgeworfen wurden, die zufälligerweise auch noch im Bild waren.
Und da hat man spätestens wieder gesehen, es geht Blizzard nicht um eine bessere Welt, um Menschenrechte oder sonst was,
es geht Blizzard schlicht und ergreifend einfach nur um Stonks.
Die sind genau auf ihrer Seite und sonst auf keiner anderen Seite und wenn ihre Seite es nützt,
für etwas zu sein, dann sind sie dafür und wenn es ihrer Seite nutzt dagegen, dann sind sie dagegen.
Das ist denen einfach wurscht. Die sind einfach nur bei sich auf ihrer Seite.
Jetzt benennen sie McCree um. Stimmt, stimmt, sie benennen McCree um.
Ähm, frag mich, frag mich, frag mich, wie McCree dann heißt.
Wobei das Witzige ist, in einem der McCree Comics, so als ich noch Overwatch Lore verfolgt habe,
wurde sogar angedeutet, dass McCree wohl nur ein Fake-Name ist.
Das könnte man sogar ganz gut einbinden.
Ja, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde das okay, dass sie das umbenennen.
Ja, ich hab da nichts dagegen. Es gibt ja Leute, die sind da voll am Wetter und sagen immer,
das ist ein Videogame-Charakter. Hey, wenn es nach einem der Leute benannt ist,
die sich da bei Blizzard nicht so mit Ruhm bekleckert haben, ist okay, verstehe ich, dass man das umbenennt.
Ähm, dass dadurch irgendeinem aber geholfen wird am Ende, das bezweifle ich.
Also das ist auch ein typischer Blizzard-Stonks-Move, dass McCree umbenannt wird.
Das ist der Stonks-Move, schaut her, wir machen was.
Blizzard geht es überhaupt nicht darum, die Welt irgendwie besser zu machen
oder irgendwie eine Zeichen zu setzen oder sonst was.
Bobby hat gesagt, Jungs, sorgt mal dafür, dass es so aussieht, als kümmern wir uns drum und machen was.
Was können wir denn machen? Ja, lass McCree umbenennen.
An sich ist es vollkommen gerechtfertigt, aber die machen das nicht aus dem Grund,
dem sie einem glauben machen wollen, sie würden es machen.
Sie machen das nämlich einfach nur für sich.
Dass die Welt guckt und sagt, hey guck mal da, Blizzard macht was.
In Wirklichkeit machen sie es nur für sich, dass sie wieder besser dastehen.
So.
Wobei, was ich auch wieder geil fand, Twitter ist ja komplett wieder übers Ziel herausgeschossen.
Ich habe gelesen, auf Twitter hat einer geschrieben, so sinngemäß, wer einen seiner Coworker nach einem Date fragt,
sollte quasi geächtet werden oder sowas.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Alter, in welcher Welt leben die Leute auf Twitter eigentlich?
Ich glaube, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht in Prozent sagen, aber ein Großteil,
also ein nicht unerheblicher Teil der Paare lernen sich auf der Arbeit kennen.
Man kann ja nicht so realitätsfremd sein und sagen, ah, das ist nicht so.
Also, in Twitter wird es teilweise komplett in die entgegengesetzte Richtung wieder übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Also, es ist halt Twitter, es ist halt Twitter.
Twitter sind wirklich schon die ganz fertigen Leute.
Ich sehe da überhaupt kein Problem drin, auf der Arbeit irgendjemand,
egal ob männlich, weiblich, wie auch immer, zu fragen.
Man muss halt akzeptieren, weil einer sagt, habe ich keinen Bock.
Und vielleicht sollte man auch nicht als Chef hingehen und seine Machtposition ausnutzen.
Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Aber wenn du Leute hast, die keine Ahnung, das seit drei Jahren zusammenarbeiten,
sich vielleicht auch so schon zueinander hingezogen fühlen,
und er sie dann fragt oder umgedreht, das ist ja in der heutigen Zeit kein Problem,
wollen wir vielleicht nach der Arbeit noch mal irgendwie was essen gehen oder so.
Ist doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Das wurde auf Twitter wieder komplett verteuflicht,
als hat wirklich einer geschrieben, das sollte geächtet werden.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, da fuck, was ist mit euch wieder los?
Egal, gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich habe übrigens, ich habe meine Xbox damals nicht gemoddet.
Ich habe meine Xbox nicht gemoddet.
Ich glaube, der Fabian hatte eine, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob der Frasier eine gemoddete Xbox hatte.
Der Fabian hatte eh gefühlt fünf Xbox und 20 Accounts.
XX der Friseur, I Frasier, I Friseur, der Friseur, der Friseur XX.
Der Fabian hatte 20 Accounts oder so, keine Ahnung.
Weil es write protected ist, das habe ich jetzt verstanden.
Ich habe im Leben nicht noch in meine Xbox gemoddet.
Okay, okay, die bohren ein Loch rein, dort wo irgendwie eine Sicherung
oder was auch immer drinne ist, die den Chip write protected macht.
Und wenn man die durch bohrt, ist der Chip da nicht mehr write protected oder wie?
Wie kommt man da überhaupt drauf?
Wie man da drauf kommt, das kann ich mir in dem Fall sogar vorstellen,
wie man da drauf kommt.
Irgendjemand hat auf den Chip geguckt, hat sich die Schematik geholt
von dem MediaTek Chip und hat sich angeguckt, wo könnte ich da was bohren müssen,
dass das nicht mehr write protected ist.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du die Schaltpläne für diesen MediaTek Chip
im Internet findest.
Oder irgendjemand hat es aufgemacht und sich unter Mikroskop angeguckt.
Siehste, siehste, Mikroskop.
Obviously, natürlich, welche, welche Lines denn sonst?
Na also, das erkennt ja nun wirklich jeder, dass das hier die write protection ist.
Also Chet, wer von euch nicht erkennt, dass diese zwei Adern
der Schreibschutz sind, dann habt ihr ja nicht aufgepasst im Streamer.
Easy as fuck, also wer das nicht sieht.
Obviosli.
Geil, so geil, ist einfach durch Sport.
By the way, es hätte schon mal seinen Vorteil gehabt,
wenn man den Trill gerade rein gemacht hat.
Guck mal, wie shabt das ist.
Da gibt es doch garantiert Schablonen und sowas für.
Ich meine, es gab CPU-Köpfschablonen und Tools und alles.
Das gab es doch dafür bestimmt auch.
Siehste, siehste, das hat man von den Griechen gelernt,
dass man so, so und so, wenn man das dann macht,
dass man exakt auf der gleichen Position rauskommt.
Man kann natürlich nur hoffen, dass die Pins immer exakt gleich sind.
Jawoll, das habe ich mir gedacht, dass es dadurch irgendwelche Schablonen für gibt.
Was ist das da oben?
Dass du nicht durchbohrst.
Ja gut, wenn du durch die Platine bohrst, ist natürlich auch doof.
Jemand Erfahrung mit Klonen als Gyra-Servers?
Äh, inwiefern?
Linux-Kiste?
Kannst einfach die Platte dehnen.
Ist es im produktiven Netz?
Also die einfachste Variante in Server zu Klonen unter Linux,
wo man sich nicht viel Gedanken machen muss,
ist DD von der einen Platte runter und auf eine andere Platte drauf.
Kannst du auch übers Netzwerk machen.
Und du kannst einfach booten davon danach.
Du hast diese Platte verwendet, und du hast die ganze Position gegrilliert.
Und es gibt auch eine LED-Licht.
Du drillst und drillst und drillst, bis die LED-Licht aufsteigt.
Das bedeutet, dass du den richtigen Pin auf die Platte drückst.
Okay, nachdem du den Pin drückt, kannst du die ganze Platte auf den PC drücken.
Das ist schon hart.
Das ist schon echt hardcore.
Kann man nicht anders nennen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das ist die ähnliche Kamikaze-Hackung von 2012 für die Xbox 360.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich viele Archive-Material für diese Episode verwendet habe,
und viele YouTube Videos von 2012 verwendet habe.
Ich werde von allen in der Beschreibung beantragen,
und von allen, die in diesem Video sind, die ich wellkredite.
Aber, wenn es irgendwelche Storys gibt, die du erzählen musst über deine Erfahrung mit den Kamikazeien,
Ich bin sicher, dass einige von euch, die da sind,
ein paar Storys zu erzählen haben.
Ich wollte mir ein Video angucken, ich hab gesehen, die Gamestar, Maurice von der Gamestar, das sind fast die einzigen Videos, die ich mir da noch angucke, hat sich drüber ausgelassen. Ich weiß nicht, okay, das ist 18 Minuten, aber der hat abgenommen, oder? Der hat mega abgenommen, was ist denn da los? Guck mal hier, der hat Ultra abgenommen. Der ist jetzt wahrscheinlich voll der Schrank unter dem Shirt.
Aber 18 Minuten, das war fast ein bisschen, fast ein bisschen lang.
Ja, weil ich wollte mir das kaufen, zu Release.
Ähm.
Und irgendwie hat er sich da drüber ausgelassen, warum es sackt.
Egal, wir gucken uns das jetzt trotzdem an.
Ich hab's noch nicht geguckt, vielleicht ist es auch halb so wild.
Die Beta von Diablo 2 Resurrected hat zwei Dinge klar gemacht.
Erstens, Diablo 2 ist immer noch...
Die Beta war deutlich zu kurz, es ging bloß bis Akt 2, das hast du ja ein paar Stunden durch, wenn du geübt bist.
...eins der besten Spiele aller Zeiten.
Wozu haben die das Ganze jetzt noch mal gemacht, also warum sollte man die Ride Protection umgehen wollen?
Äh, achso, du meinst wegen dem Hack?
Naja, dass du das Laufwerk flaschen kannst.
Ach guck mal, Jano ist auch da.
Du konntest Custom-Firmware auf dein DVD-Laufwerk flaschen.
Microsoft hat allerdings den Chip drauf gemacht, der Ride Protected war und du konntest es nicht mehr flaschen.
Wenn du es geflasht hast, konntest du selbstgebrannte DVDs abspielen, mit Xbox spielen.
So, dementsprechend mussten sie da reinbohren und die Ride Protection für den Chip ausschalten, damit du Custom-Firmware flaschen kannst.
Und wenn du Custom-Firmware geflasht hast, dann konntest du selbstgebrannte DVDs mit Xbox spielen.
Aber zweitens, es ist trotzdem in manchen Bereichen...
Also ich muss sagen, grafisch fand ich das richtig gut gemacht.
Ich hab ja die Beta auch gespielt, nachdem ich auf Twitch Zugang bekommen hab.
Grafisch hab ich selten gesehen, dass ein Remake wirklich so das Original widerspiegelt, nur in besserer Qualität.
Okay, lass mich raten, ich weiß jetzt schon, worüber er meckert.
Ich predicte mal, ich predicte mal.
Er meckert, dass man nur mit F-Tasten die Skills durchschalten kann.
Ja, weil Diablo 2 ist es so, du hast jetzt nicht etwa linke Maustaste, rechte Maustaste, mittlere Maustaste, WASD und sonst was.
Diablo 2 hast du nur Skills auf der rechten oder linken Maustaste und du musst die Skills mit F1 bis F8 oder so durchschalten.
Da wird er drüber meckern, 100 pro.
Ähm, und ansonsten, also das ist auch das erste, was mir aufgefallen ist, wo ich mir gedacht hab, okay, das ist halt, das ist halt oldschool, aber ist halt irgendwie 2021 nicht mehr das.
Über was, über was könnte er denn sonst noch meckern?
Ah, dass man nicht mehr offline spielen kann vielleicht. Ich glaub, das geht nämlich nicht mehr, ich glaub, man kann nicht mehr offline spielen, zumindest ging das in der Beta nicht.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Ne, Diablo 2 stream ich nicht, das ist langweilig zu gucken.
Na dann, erzähl's uns, Moris.
Aber wie wir alle wissen, bin ich der ultimative Diablo Overlord und Blizzard macht alles, was ich will sagen, deswegen will ich in diesem Video meine erhabene Autorität nutzen, um darzulegen, warum Diablo 2 in meinen Augen mehr Mut zur Veränderung zeigen sollte.
Leider konnte man in der Beta kein Nekro spielen, Nekro ist die Easy Mode Start klassisch schlechthin in dem Game.
Activision Blizzard wird derzeit vom Staat Kalifornien verklagt, für angeblich katastrophale und entwürdigende Arbeitsbedingungen, die sich über Jahre hinweg durch die Firma gezogen haben sollen, und das muss du erstmal schaffen, das musst du erstmal schaffen, dass sich der Staat Kalifornien verklagt, nicht irgendein ehemaliger Mitarbeiter, nein, Kalifornien verklagt dich.
Ich kann jeden verstehen, der unter diesen Umständen sagt, diese Firma will ich boykottieren, ich persönlich habe mich trotzdem entschieden, weiter über Blizzard Spiele zu berichten, denn die werden ja nicht nur von den Chefs da oben gemacht, die für die Arbeitsbedingungen verantwortlich sind, sondern auch und vor allem von den ganzen Entwicklern am Boden, die darunter gelitten haben und trotzdem ihr Herzblut in diese Spiele gesteckt haben.
Diese Entwickler kämpfen aktuell für ein besseres Blizzard und ich persönlich wünsche mir so sehr, dass sie damit Erfolg haben, dass sie Blizzard zu einer Firma machen, deren Spiele ich wieder guten Gewissens einfach nur lieben kann, dabei würde ich sie nicht unterstützen, wenn ich einfach gar nicht mehr über ihre Arbeit berichten würde, stattdessen will ich weiter darüber berichten, sowohl über die Spiele als auch über die Bedingungen, über das Gute wie das Schlechte.
Das ist sehr diplomatisch gesagt.
Wir haben ein sehr ausführliches Video zu diesem ganzen Skandal mit meinen Kollegen Heiko und Leia gemacht, das empfehle ich euch, wenn ihr euch darüber mehr informieren wollt, denn es ist ein enorm wichtiges Thema, dass man nicht totschweigen sollte, aber wie gesagt, will ich auch über die Spiele weiterhin reden und darum soll es heute gehen.
Fangen wir mal an damit, was meine ich denn, wenn ich...
Jetzt die Chat sagt, die Corona Pass App ist Two-Head, die kann keine ÖÄÖS anzeigen. Kann sie Emojis anzeigen? Das ist eigentlich das Wichtige, wer braucht Umlaute, wenn Emojis gehen?
Ich sage, Diablo 2 ist in manchen Bereichen schlecht gealtert. Ich meine damit vor allem einen Bereich, Bedienung und Spielkomfort. Man könnte sich da jede Menge Beispiele raussuchen, das umständliche Tränkemanagement, das viel zu kleine Inventar...
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt. Das Inventar ist auch so ein Ding, das ist zwar nah am Original dran, aber gerade das rumhantieren mit den Tränken, weiß ich nicht, ob das hätte sein muss.
Ich persönlich habe mir ja gedacht, als ich die Beta gespielt habe, ihr kennt das vielleicht oder für die Leute, die Diablo 2 gespielt haben, später wird das so aussehen, dass in dem Inventar gar kein Platz mehr drin ist, weil du das Inventar quasi, bis auf wenige Slots voll hast mit Charms, die Stats steigern.
Also ich hätte es durchaus für sinnvoll gefunden, wenn man das so macht, wie beispielsweise Pass of Diablo das gemacht hat. Also das ist ja quasi ein Mod. Hab ich hier irgendwo? Da. Das ist ein Mod für Diablo 2 gewesen.
Die haben ein extra Charms Inventory. Du kannst auch nicht mehr Charms, also Glücksbringer mit Stats Bonus ins Inventar legen, wie in Vanilla, aber du hast auch ein zweites Inventar für Drops, was ich sehr, sehr sinnvoll fand, äh, deine Stapeln kann, aber ich will mich vor allem auf einen Kernaspekt konzentrieren, die Fähigkeitensteuerung.
Denn da hat Diablo 2 nach heutigem Maßstab ein regelrecht absurdes Thema. Ich wusste es, dass es kommt. Ich habe für meine Fähigkeiten nur die Maustasten. Und F1 bis F8 oder so. Nur bestimmen, welche Fähigkeit auf der Maustaste liegt, um dann die Maustaste drücken zu müssen, um sie auszulösen.
Und dann zu wechseln und wieder die Maustaste drücken. Das ist wirklich nicht zeitgemäß. Das ist doch absurd aus heutiger Sicht, wo sich seit Jahren die Skillleiste mit Hotkeys als Genre Standard etabliert hat, wo ich einfach mit einem Knopfdruck direkt die Fähigkeit meiner Wahl auslösen kann.
Und das ist einfach ein definitiv besseres System. Das System von Diablo 2 tut nichts, außer mehr Knopfdrücke hinzuzufügen und damit den Kampffluss zu verschlechtern. Und dass die Entwickler das nicht verbessern wollen, ist doppelt glitzhare, weil es gibt ein besseres System in Diablo 2 Resurrected. Aber halt nur fürs Gamepad.
Wenn ich ein Gamepad am PC anschließe, wechselt das Spiel sofort zu einem Menü mit Fähigkeitenleiste, wo ich dann... Ja, warum macht man das nicht optional? Das ist tatsächlich deutlich, deutlich komfortabler und besser in 2021.
Es ergibt in Diablo 2 auch wirklich keinen Sinn, das weiterhin so zu machen. Es ist trotzdem jeder Skill unabhängig voneinander. Also wäre es beispielsweise so gewesen in Diablo 2 aus Balancing-Gründen, dass wenn man den Skill switcht, dass der alte Skill dann aufhört zu wirken.
Das hätte ich verstanden, dass man das aus Balancing-Gründen dann beibehält. Aber das ist ja gar nicht so. Das ist ja gar nicht so. Du kannst in Diablo 2 ohne Probleme rüber switchen, Pads beschwören und dann auf einen anderen Skill switchen und die Pads bleiben trotzdem da.
Du kannst Firewall irgendwo hinsetzen, Skill switchen und es ist immer noch da. Aus dem Gesicht, es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, es nicht so zu machen. Da gäbe ich ihm einen Rechner.
Pass mal auf, ich könnte das mit Controller-Emulator spielen. Ich spiele am Rechner mit Maus und Tastatur, tue aber so, als wäre es ein Controller. Next Level.
Warum bleibt das nicht mehr auf? Ein intrinsischen Wert, Alter. Jetzt für Nation.
Der erste ist einfach ehrfurcht vor dem Original. Sie wollen dem Geist des Klassikers so treu bleiben wie möglich. Und das verstehe ich total, das ist enorm wichtig.
Jede Modernisierung birgt die Gefahr, dass man sich damit zu weit vom Kern des Originals entfernt und das Spiel vielleicht sogar verschlechtert. Aber was ist denn der Kern von Diablo 2?
Ich glaube, das sehe ich ein bisschen anders. Ja, es wird bestimmt ehrfurcht vor dem Original sein, aber dafür hast du ja eigentlich sowas wie einen Director. Der im Prinzip so Sachen, wie soll ich sagen, Wege, wie das gemacht wird, erproben lässt, festlegt.
Also quasi irgendein Regisseur, quasi sowas in der Richtung, Projektleiter oder keine Ahnung. Und ich glaube einfach, dass sie selbst keine Ahnung mehr haben, was den Geist des Originals ausmacht.
Das glaube ich bei vielen Remakes mittlerweile, dass sie es remaken, weil es Geld bringt und sie aber eigentlich gar keine Ahnung mehr haben von der Essenz des Originals.
Warum ihr dieses Spiel immer noch in so liebevoller Erinnerung habt und warum ihr es vielleicht auch heute gerne noch spielt, was ist denn dann der Grund dafür? Ich denke dann zum Beispiel an die großartige Atmosphäre von Diablo 2, an diesen düsteren Horror, den bis heute kaum ein anderes Hack'n'Slay so gut eingefangen hat.
Ich denke an das brillante Klassendesign, an die vielfältigen und richtig coolen Skilltrees für jeden Helden. Der Necromant aus Diablo 2 ist bis heute.
Also was nervt dich eigentlich am meisten an deinem Beruf? Ich bin Programmierer und am meisten nervt es sich, wenn sich Leute dauernd beschweren, aber dann auch nichts machen wollen, um es zu verbessern. Also was mich nervt, das hat wenig was damit zu tun, ob ich jetzt Sachen programmiere oder sonst wie das, was mich nervt ist, das liegt jetzt aber, wie gesagt, das ist nicht direkt das, was mich an meinem Beruf nervt, sondern dort, wo ich arbeite, dass Entscheidung und Umsetzung oftmals nichts miteinander zu tun hat.
Also es wird irgendwas Abstraktes entschieden. Okay, ich mach mal ein Beispiel. Also bei uns ist die beste Variante, um auf Neuerungen zu reagieren, einfach zwei Monate abzuwarten. Weil von 90% der Neuerungen hörst du nach zwei Monaten nichts mehr, weil sie irrelevant sind oder man sie doch nicht mehr haben will.
Also es kommt irgendjemand und sagt, hey Max, es ist jetzt ganz wichtig XY zu machen, dann machst du einfach zwei Monate XY nicht. Und wenn XY nach zwei Monaten immer noch relevant ist, dann kannst du damit anfangen.
Es werden bei uns wöchentlich neue Dinger und Änderungen und Sachen verkündet und immer mit einem Nachdruck so als wäre das jetzt das wichtigste von der Welt und von 90% der Sachen hörst du nie wieder was.
Selfmade Ice. Dankeschön für 14 Monate Hypersubscription. Das nervt mich. Das nervt mich. Und was mich persönlich ein bisschen nervt ist, also so aus dem Umfeld, dass man, wie soll ich sagen, schwer, dass die Leute es schwer erkennen, was man eigentlich
braucht, warum man manche Sachen braucht. Zum Beispiel ist es bei uns lange Zeit so gewesen, wir hatten Linux Notebooks, womit du Linux mit Abstand am besten administrieren kannst, aber sie sind jetzt seit Jahren schon hinterher, dass wir auch alle Windows Notebooks verwenden.
Aber es haut nie hin. Es haut nie hin, weil immer irgendwelche Dinger da nicht richtig ordentlich funktionieren. Also sind auf der einen Seite nicht in der Lage, unser Windows Zeug ordentlich zu machen, aber auf der anderen Seite sagen sie nach dem Motto Leute, ihr dürft kein Niedungsmal verwenden, was dazu führt, dass man permanent in so einem halb legalen Grauzonenbereich operiert. Das ist auch ein absolutes Unding meiner Ansicht nach.
Nee, habe ich nicht gehört, aber ich habe vom Ellen Wake Remake gehört, was ich sehr nice finde, weil Ellen Wake eines der besten Spiele überhaupt ist. Wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt eher eine Fortsetzung erhofft hätte, weil das Ending von Ellen Wake jetzt nicht so erfüllend war.
Ja, du kannst über Paypal bezahlen in Indien YouTube. Hast du gesub-Chained nur? Das kann mir überhaupt nichts. Ach da, doch hier, Massive Subscription. Huge.
Habe ich nicht gesehen. Hast du Control gespielt? Ja, aber Control habe ich abgebrochen. Das war das erste Remedy Spiel, was ich nicht durchgespielt habe, weil ich das einfach nur langweilig fand.
Mich hat die Story nach irgendwie 10 Stunden nichts oder ja, so lange habe ich nicht gespielt, sag mal irgendwie 5-6 Stunden nicht sonderlich gepackt und das Gameplay fand ich auch nicht gut.
Nicht so spannend. Ja, also Control ist das erste Remedy Game, was ich nicht durchgespielt habe.
So, gucken wir mal weiter. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Genau. Das stimmt, Necro ist das beste. Necro ist die absolute Noob-Klasse in Diablo 2.
Also wer keine Ahnung hat, mit was er starten soll, startet Necro einfach ganz normales Summoning-Bild. Easy Mode bis schwierigster Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Das stimmt. Ja, Diablo 3 fand ich zu langweilig. Das stimmt. PoE ist, das ist übrigens das PoE 2, was immer noch nicht raus ist.
Wann kommt eigentlich Path of Exile 2? Wollen wir es nicht schon letztes Jahr releasen? Das ist wirklich extrem hardcore.
Wo ist denn Path of Exile 2 Release jetzt ein? Warte mal.
Wo ist denn 2022? Okay, okay, dauert noch ewig. Die haben PoE mit der letzten Liga getötet. Das habe ich gelesen, da haben die total viele Sachen genervt und angepasst und es waren ganz viele gepisst.
Ich habe die letzten drei Ligen nicht gespielt. Ich habe nur am Rande mitbekommen, was war. Sie wollten ja ursprünglich was machen, dass die Leute quasi nur noch selbst durch die Maps springen.
Aber sie haben es wohl nicht geschafft, diese Instant-Death-Momente zu fixen. Ich habe es nicht richtig mitgekriegt, was Path of Exile passiert ist, aber nächste Liga sind die Leute doch wieder am Start, wenn die Sache gefixt ist.
Ich habe es nicht richtig mitgekriegt, was Path of Exile passiert ist. Ich habe es nicht richtig mitgekriegt, was Path of Exile passiert ist.
Ich habe es nicht richtig mitgekriegt, was Path of Exile passiert ist.
Ich habe es nicht richtig mitgekriegt.
Max reaktet auf.